tehát 180 ember meghallgatta az idejét
odaadta én hálátlan lennék hogyha azt
mondanám hogy ez kevés biztonságba
vagyok olyan szempontból hogy ezzel a
témával játszhatok mert nem ez nem ez a
mindennapi megélhetésem tehát nem kell a
miérrtem olyan legyen hogy az bárminek
is megfeleljen szerintem ez lesz a jövő
tehát hogyha most nem is ebben a
választási ciklusban de négy év múlva
romániában is szerintem az lesz hogy
hogy egyre inkább az lesz hogy lesznek
majd ezek a nagyon híres és hitelesnek
tartott műsorvezetők és akkor mint ahogy
most drágos petráru is egy egy
hitelesnek tartott valaki és akkor
gyakorlatilag ha nem mész el az is
elmond valamit rólad ha elmész akkor
pedig egy csomó minden ki fog
[Zene]
derülni sziasztok a következő vendégem
józsa levi lesz a csakab baj podcast
házigazdája akivel egy csomó mindenről
beszélgettünk az elmúlt egy évről
ugyanis most lett egy éves a csakab baj
podcast hogy miket tanult én miket
tanultam tőle mi is ez a podcast kultúra
és erdélyben hogyan fog megjelenni ez
valamint a politikában a választásokban
hogyan jelennek például az amerikai
választásokban úgyhogy tarts velünk és
ne felejtsen feliratkozni a csatornánkra
köszöntök mindenkit köszöntöm az összes
kedves nézőt a mai napi vendégem józsa
levente most már mondhatnám azt hogy
veterán podcaster és az az igazság hogy
én nagyon vártam hogy most lejöjjünk
egyet beszélgetni mert mert egy év
eltelt amióta elindult a te saját
podcasted és rengeteg kérdésem van
úgyhogy üdvözöllek az az én műsorombaan
ezúttal üdvözöllek én is és mindenkit
aki hallgatja és nézi igen hát meg is
néztem a a naptárban hogy november 7-én
volt az amikor leültünk először forgatni
emlékszem hogy annyira izgultam tele
voltam félelemmel vajon jól fogom-e a
szavakat formálni vajon a gondolatok
eszembe jutnak-e sőt utólag eszembe
jutott hogy nem jutottak eszembe
úgyhogy úgyhogy emlékszem egy évvel
ezelőtt az volt az első amikor fények
mellett beszéltem tehát azért így furcsa
érzés így a a hallgatóknak mondom amikor
amikor a háttérből világít a a fény meg
oldalról viszont kábé olyan öt perc után
meg lehet szokni
egy év eltelt kicsit mesélnél erről az
egy évről hogy egy kezdjük azzal hogy
amikor nekiindultál benned volt-e
félelem hogyan indultál neki ennek az
egész
podcastnekm érdekes igen hát talán amit
a legjobban ezzel kapcsolatban ki tudok
emelni az az
hogy volt egy tehát én arról arról
vagyok idézőjelben híres ami magam
magamat illeti legalábbis én magamról
azt gondolom hogy és ezt egy ilyen nagy
hibának is tartottam hogy folyamatosan
csapongtam az elmúlt 10-12 évben olyan
szinten hogy amikor valamilyen új
ötletem volt akkor azt nagyon-nagyon
gyorsan beleugrottam és
és nem feltétlen vártam ki azt az időt
ami kellett volna hozzá hanem hanem
jutott valami eszembe jutott és azt azt
konkrétan olyan példámim is vannak hogy
két percen belül érkeztem tehát hogy
ilyen ilyen szinten nem vártam azzal
hogy ez biztos h hogy hogy ilyen téren
kiforhat
viszont ezt ilyen nagyon erőltetve és
nagyon nehezen visszafogtam magamba az
elmúlt évekbe ez a podcast dolog volt
olyan amit amit még úgy megengedtem
magamnak hogy na jó akkor ezt is el
kellene kezdeni mert ugye nekünk régebb
volt egy próbálkozásunk és azt viszont
abbahagyásunk után azt gondoltam vagyis
ilyen nagyon nagy hiányérzetem maradt és
tudtam hogy ezt még egyszer folytatni
fogom na de visszatérve amit így látok
az az hogy mondjuk ha nézem az elmúlt 10
évet nagyon kevés olyan év volt mint ez
az év hogy ennyit ennyit tanultam és
ennyit fejlődtem valamiben illetve nem
is csak valamiben hanem úgy úgy anblock
mindenről
és ez is most ha ki kellene emeljek egy
ilyen kedvenc dolog a
podcastezésbe ami ami egy kicsit magamra
értem vagy az én értelmezésemben az az
hogy hihetetlen hogy h mennyit lehet
fejlődni tanulni
minden egyes epizód alatt de ez tényleg
így van ez tényleg így van és emlékszem
hogy a médiaműhely az a közös
kezdeményezésünként még még a falak
csupaszon fehíen voltak és már akkor
berendeztett hoztál virágokat a háttérbe
és engem nagyon meglepett ez a tempó
amivel haladsz előre és ez a bátorság
hogy hogy annak ellenére azért látam
hogy izgultál te is annak ellenére mégis
le tudtunk ülni beszélgetni és és és
egész jó lett az a beszélgetés nem
mondom hogy hogy nem javítanék rajta
utólag de hát mit tudtunk akkor még és
igazából egy év után is mennyi mindent
tanultunk és mennyit fogunk még tanulni
valószínűleg úgyhogy
úgyhogy ezt ezt
tudtam csodálni benned hogy hogy hogy
milyen bátorsággal nekivágsz egy olyan
doméniumnak ami ami szűz terület
valójában neked is nekem is
igen nyilván sokat kell tanulni például
azt hogy amikor te valamit mondasz akkor
én a háttérb folyamatosan n mondja ühüm
ühüm mert akkor ez a vágó mindig lekell
az én magsáót iatt húzza de amit most az
egyből az öt perc alatt észreevettem így
mintogyha én is podcasterként legyek de
igen hát olyan olyan szempontból
mindenképp szűz volt ez a terület hogy
hogy azt látom én is hogy bár
beleugrottunk ebbe és egyből a mélyvízbe
tehát nem nem olyan szinten kezdtünk
ugye hogy leraktuk a telefonunknak a
hangrögzítőjét és elkezdtünk venni
felvenni hanganyagokat hanem itt tényleg
egy elég elég mély vízbe ugrottunk ami
mindenféle akár a technikát akár a
felkészültséget igényli de amit amit a
amit említettél hogy hogy miért haladok
így vagy hogy mi tűnhet kívülről
haladásnak
én én ezt tényleg nagyon nagyon kell
azon dolgozzak hogy visszafogjam magam
és ezt is érzem hogy azért sokkal több
tudna lenni ebben nap mint nap csak
nyilván van mellette egy olyan munka
amibő meg kell élni van egy olyan munka
amit egyébként ugyanúgy sőt nem hogy
ugyanúgy mert nem is akarom
hasonlítgatni de hogy szeretek és megis
élek belőle nyilván van család meg egyéb
olyan más dolgok is amik nem tudom sport
satöbbi satöbbi nagyon sok mindent ki
lehet még ebből hozni de de itt nálam
amúgy a nagy harc az nem az hogy hogy mi
lenne a következő hanem az hogy tényleg
visszafogjam magamat és és ne öt perc
után most nem tudom ezt tehát nagyon sok
szó van olyan olyan érdekes nem tudom
hogy te vagy-e így hogy hogy mész csak
simán az utcán vagy meghallgatsz egy
műsort eszedbe jüt egy téma hogy azta
erről én is beszélgetnék és akkor rögtön
elkezdesz gondolkodni azon hogy már
holnap bemenné a kamerák elellé hogy ezt
a témát kibontsa az azér nem annyira
erőteljes bennem mint benned aha de van
van úgyhogy lehet hogy pont szerencsés
is vagyok hogy annyira nem intenzív ez
mert akkor szaggatna szét
talán a biznisvilág ilyen szempontból
visszafogott mert a biznisvilágan nem
lehet bármit megtenni tehát véges
erőforrásokkal kell bánni és türelmesnek
kell lenni lehet hogy ez az ami ami
visszafogta bennem igen meg ez nekem
valószínű egy hiányosságom is mert bár
2018 óta én
is lehet azt mondani hogy
adminisztrátorként is dolgozom egy kis
vállalkozásba sajátunkba de de azért
mégis nálam az dominál hogy fotósként
hogy éltam az elmúlt 12 évemet és és ott
vz viszont nem feltétlen vannak olyan
helyzetek amikor vissza kell fogjam
magam sőt tehát hogyha van nekem egy
ötletem vagy egy ha mondjuk ott vagyunk
egy cégnél és fotózunk valamit vagy egy
eseménnyel ha jön egy ilyen inger akkor
az csak jó sőt hogy egy fotózásb ez egy
pozitívum tud lenni az hogy én igen a
költsége kicsi tehát belefekteted és
kipróbál igen meg meg azt szeretik egy
egy fotósba legalábbis amit én ki tudok
emelni és látom hogy pozitív
visszajelzés velem kapcsolatban hogy
hogy a például talán a legtöbb termék
amit fotóztam az az a péktermék de a mai
napig ha ha pékterméket raknak elém egy
kenyeret vagy egy kiflit akkor akkor
ezek az ingerek azok amik pluszot tudnak
hozzáadni a fotóhoz vagy nem lesz
ugyanolyan mint a másé mert úgy sokszor
ez van hogy ja hát én nem akarok olyan
fotót mint a másé na de kicsit
elkalandoztam
igen hát itt a legfontosabb kérdés az
hogy
nekifogtunk te is kész elindítottál egy
ket én is egy rengeteg időt energiát és
nem nem kevés pénzt is belefektettünk
abba hogy ez az egész stúdió létre
tudjon jönni de a legfontosabb az hogy
miért tehát hogy mi motivál téged hogy
egy egy ennyi energiát és időt és pénzt
belefektess abba hogy legyen egy egy egy
egy podcasted mi mi a célod van egy azt
már egy pár helyen említettem mindenféle
beszélgetésben de ilyen
magánbeszélgetésekre gondolok főleg hogy
van egy nagy hát van egy nagy előnyünk
azzal kapcsolatban hogy
hogy hogy is fejezzem ki magam tehát
biztonságba vagyok olyan szempontból
hogy ezzel a témával játszhatok mert nem
ez nem ez a mindennapi megélhetésem üüm
ilyen szempontból meg nagyon sokat
tesztelhetek is és és ilyen szempontból
meg a miért is egy picit átalakulhat
olyan szempontból hogy nem kell tehát
nem kell a miértem olyan legyen hogy az
bárminek is megfeleljen mert hogyha
mondjuk én azt mondanám hogy na jó
hónaptól ebből kell megéljek akkor az
hogy miért csinálom az lehet egy picit
átalakulni olyan szempontból hogy na jó
akkor meg kell próbáljak minél
aktualitás aktuálisabb dologgal
foglalkozni minél több közélettel minél
több olyan tartalomalá így van így van
ilyen szempontból hogy ez nem fenyeget
így igazából a saját időmmel és ugye
sokszor a mások idejével is de a saját
időmmel főleg tudok játszadozni és akkor
ugy a ilyen sz ontból meg a miért is az
és bármennyire furcsa lehet kimondani de
az első számú az az hogy hogy én
fejlődjek és ez volt a legnagyobb
motivációm benne hogy engem nagyon
érdekel hát ki lehet mondani hogy minden
viszont de miért pont podcast azért mert
ezt azért mert ez megad azért egy olyan
szigort is tehát hogyha mondjuk akkor
induljunk ki onnan hogy honnan jött ez a
gondolatom nagyon sok olyan cégnél
jártam az elmúlt 12 évben de nem csak
cégnél hanem emberekkel is találkoztam
tehát eseményeken bármilyen fotózáson
ahol egy olyan emberbe vagy egy olyan
témába bukkansz ami ami így is
fogalmaztam annó a traileremben ez azóta
úgy belém ragadt hogy hogy olyan téma
amit úgy úgy azt érzed hogy azt a jobb
tudna lenni a világ ha ezt mindenkinek
megmutatnál vagy mindenkivel hallatnád
ezt a témát vagy ezt a történetet na
most ez ilyen
nagyon szépen meg nagyon ide isnak
hangzódhat de de ez az igazság hogy
hogy ezeket tényleg kifel kellene
hangosítani és akkor azért podcast mert
ha eljom ezt a személyt valahova mondjuk
nem tudom kávézni és tényleg
megérdeklődöm hogy te figyelj meséld de
hogy egyébként miért is gyártjátok
ezeket a termékeket az az még mindig ott
marad egy olyan burokba amivel azt érzem
hogy nem lehet semmit hozzátenni a
közösségünknek a a a további életéhez
vagy
fejlődéséhez ha meg azt akarom hogy
ezeket felhangosítsuk akkor meg
gondolkodni kell hogy milyen formátum
létezik erre na most nyilván mindenkivel
lehetne egy szép dokumentumfilmet
forgatni mert talán akkor azt mondom
hogy ez lenne a a csúcsa bár nem akarom
leedegradálni a podcastet emiatt de de
hogy mondjuk akkor mindenkiről lehetne
forgatni egy nagy dokumentumfilmet de a
dokumentumfilmnek megint egy más
más a formátuma mert ott ott nagyon sok
múlik a látványon nagyon sok múlik a
vágáson ugye ma már azt is mondják hogy
hogy a dokumentumfilmek sem azok amik
annoó régebb tehát ott is most már
nagyon sok mindent befolyásolnak csak
azt hogy hogy valakit milyen oldalról
mutatok már elüthet a realitástól mert
valami olyan dolgot emelek ki ami nem az
ami kellene egy dokumentalista jellegű
legyen és a podcast a legalkalmasabb
olyan szempontból egy hogy hatékonyság
is vagy hatékonyság szempontjából is
költségileg is egy teljesen más illetve
ha sokat beszélsz valakivel és nem az a
lényeg most hogy hogy mutassam is
kamerán hanem tényleg leülsz és szemtől
szembe beszélgetsz akkor akkor teljesen
más hangulatot vagy teljesen más
őszinteséget tud adni mint mondjuk egy
film és akkor ez a válaszom erre hogy
miért podcast mert egyszerűen ez a
legalkalmasabb ahhoz hogy valakitől
megtudj egy témát
részletesen érezzed is valamilyen
formában meg a nézők is érezzék hogy az
mennyire őszinte magából a terjedelméből
és a feltett
kérdésekből és egyszerűen ez ez ez a
szerintem jelenleg a meg meg ugye
nyilván az is hogy ezt utána hogyan
publikálod és hol publikálod mert az is
az egyik talán a az egyik legfontosabb
hogy hogy azzal a podcastel utána mit
csinálsz vogy milyen formában publikálod
a nagy közönségnek igen ezek amúgy amúgy
teljesen egyetértek főleg azzal a
részével hogy hogy egy más közeget
jelent mag maga a podcast tehát amit
amit én így megfogalmaztam most
tizenvalamennyi rész után
hogy másfél órán keresztül nem tud egy
ember szerepet játszani tehát vagy vagy
teljesen összeomlik a podcast tehát mi
közben beszélgetünk egy egy időután
elfáradnak azok az emberek akik akik
valamilyen szerepet játszanak tehát egy
a a podcastnek a a a hangulatából
érződik hogy ez most őszinte vagy pedig
nem
őszinte tehát hogy ilyen szempontból egy
néző hogyha figyel és általában pedig
figyelnek tehát a komment szekciókban
podcastteknél lehet látni hogy
tűpontosan figyelnek az emberek a a
minden egyes rezdülésre minden egyes
hanglejtésre
úgyhogy úgyhogy a podcastnek a formátuma
megengedi azt hogy egy egy olyan közeg
legyen ami amúgy a a városban hogyha
találkozol valakivel vagy leülsz egy
kávéra az nem történik meg beülsz egy
kávézóba egy fél órára úgyhogy közbe zün
meg a háttérben egy csomó zaj közben a
telefonját nézi öt percenként valahi
megrezdül elvonja a figyelmét ilyen
szempontból tényleg egy ilyen nagyon
idealisztikus közeget biztosít a podcast
hogy másfél órán keresztül osztatlan
figyelmed van és és és nagyon-nagyon
fókuszáltan tudsz beszélni azzal a másik
személel íg van ez egy ez egy ez egy
nagyon furcsa érzés nagyon fárasztó is
főleg hogyha ha tényleg intenzívvé válik
ez a podcast és és és figyelünk egymásra
és egymás gondolataira építünk ez
valójában egy kollektív gondolkodás
amikor elkezdünk mind a ketten
gondolkozni valami komplexről ja igen
itt az jut eszembe csak hogy pont pont
az elmúlt epizódjaim között volt egy
ilyen közel három órás epizód és ott az
egyik srác aki benne szerepelt de
egyébként másoktól is hallottam vissza
ilyen kisségúnyosan hogy hogy te ezt a
kutya se fogja meghallgatni vagy mi ez
hogy három órás vagy kinek van nap
napjainkban ideje három órát
végighallgatni én egyáltalán ezt nem lát
vagyis én egyáltalán nem ezt gondolom
tehát jó nyilván másak a számok tehát
most nem kell nem tudom én itt
versenyezni egy nem tudom egy tv
csúcsidő idében lefutott nem tudom én
milyen reklámmal mondjuk nem tudom megy
egy forma egy verseny amit több millióan
néznek egyszerre és ott a csúcsidőben ha
bevágnak egy reklámot nyilván az egy
olyan számot produkál hogy nem ehhez
kell hasonlítani vagy nem egy felfutott
tiktok videóhoz kell hasonlítani mer
ugye most mindenki ehhez hasonlítja nem
de de én azt látom hogy egy három órás
műsorra is nagyon igény van sőt egyhogy
nem is akarom én ebbe a korlátba
egyébként bele szorítani magamat tehát
ö figyelve arra hogy ne játsszak
senkinek az idejével mondjuk ha nem
tudom a samu aki a háttérbe dolgozik
neki se játszó az idejével vagy az én
saját projektjeimnek az idejével se vagy
a családoméval de ettől függetlenül én
például nem akarok megszabni ilyen
határokat és miért az volt a válaszom
erre hogy ki fogja megnézni ezeket a
hosszúakat hogy nem számít most hogy ki
nézi meg mert tudom hogy úgyis aki
akarja az megnézi de figyeljétek a
csatornámat és hogyha meg fogtok látni
ilyen ö hat hé órás beszélg etéseket
rajta na azt gondolom hogy akkor leszek
a azon a ponton amit amit én
nagyonnagyon tehát akkor leszek azon a
ponton amikor azt érzem hogy na igen
innentől elkezdtem tényleg podcaster
lenni mert én például nagyon vágyom és
nagyon izgat az hogy egyszer majd
valamikor valószínű nem még a következő
egy évben bár mitőlne elkapok egy olyan
személyt akivel akár hét órán keresztül
le vagyok üve és és beszélgetünk egy
adott témába amibe simán belefér az hogy
igen jó most akkor kérek egy új
pohárvizet vagy épp pillanat k kiugrok a
mosdóba de de az egy nagyon vagány dolog
mer mert képzeld el egy ilyen másfél
órás műsort 7é órán keresztül az azért
hát az eszméletlenül fárasztó hát én
emlékszem hogy hogy én mennyire ki az
első két epizód után annyira kifáradtam
hogy rendesen haza kellett menjek és
lefeküdjek mer nagyon nagyon nagyon
intenzív volt de lex friedmannek volt
most egy pár hónapja egy olyan sorozat
amikor egy leültében nyolc órán
keresztül beszélt ilon muskkal és a a a
neurollingnek a vezetőivel és pú
eszméletlen én az elejét tudtam meg az
első két órát tudtam csak meghallgatni
belőle igen
hát én amikor ugyanezt a saját
epizódomban az epizódjaimban én nézem
folyamatosan a statisztikákat és
egyfolytában gondolkozok azon hogy
vagyis hogy hogy küzdök magammal egyik é
nem szeretné hogy minél többen nézzék
meg másik oldalról pedig az van hogy ez
nem helyes motivációss akkor akkor
ilyenkor a a lelki kezemre csapok hogy
vigyázz mert ez nem nem helyes
motivációimmal nem helyes motivációval
közelítem meg viszont azért mégis csak
ott van hogy ha ha már csinálunk valamit
és szívvel lélekkel csináljuk akkor jobb
hogyha beleadunk apait anyait tehát
reméljük hogy fogják nézni az emberek és
tényleg minőségi az amit csinálunk és
akkor így nézegettem a statisztikákat és
azt hiszem pont a bence edites epizódnál
hasított így belém hogy
ezt valami 200 valamennyi órán keresztül
nézték meg összesen lehet hogy most már
felmehet azóta 300-ra vagyis hogyha most
a másfél órás epizódot nézzük mint
hogyha 180 ember ült volna és hallgatta
volna végig csak nem ugyanabban a
pillanatban hanem ki hajnalba futás
közben vezetés közben több részletbe
valaki több részletbe ez a szép benne
hogy hogy hogy ilyen formában sokkal
több ember tudja meghallgatni ugyanazt
az információt mint hogyha most
meghérdetnénk egy egy előadást a
művelődési házba és akkor este 700
órakor benenceed itel leülünk
beszélgetni
:30-ig tehát 180 ember meghallgatta az
idejét odaadta én én hálátlan lennék
hogyha azt mondanám hogy ez kevés tehát
hogy hogy és ez egy olyan epizód ami ami
azért már egy jó párszor megtörtént
tehát hogy még volt egy pár epizódom ami
ami népszerűbb lett ami amit többen
néztek
viszont viszont nagyon kíváncsi lennék
hogy ha most így végigmegyünk most hány
epizódod ment ki eddig hányat
forgattatok le hát 24 24 24 ment ki mire
ezz adás kimegy a 24 iss már kint lesz
illetve forgattunk még másokat is most a
a 24-et én ezzel a két hetente érkező
sose tudom minek nevezzem nevezzük
stabil két hetente érkező műsoromnak de
mellette volt még elég sok tesztelés
egyéb formátumokban is de mondjuk úgy
hogy a 24 összeadva azért már a 30-at
elattta helyhagytuk hm melyik volt a
legnépszerűbb
epizódot hát a legnépszerűbb azért azért
vigyáznék és kicsit visszakötnék az
előző számokkal való
vívódásoddalra mert egyértelműen a két
legnézettebb leg népszerűbb műsorom az
egy olyan olyan két műsor ahol nagyon
sokat adtunk a látványnak is nem csak a
a beszélgetésnek most nem éreztem egyik
műsorban se hogy kevesebb lenne a
beszélgetés amiatt hogy látványban is
adtunk csak ahhoz hasonló az előző
dokumentumfilmes jellegét adtuk meg
kicsit tesztelve saját magunkat is hogy
mit lehetne egyébként még kihozni
ezekből és nyilván itt már közre játszik
az is hogy hogy abban a pillanatban hogy
te látványban is adsz valamit
már be tudsz húzni olyan embereket is
akik nem biztos hogy egyébként csak
hallgatnák ezért is lehet megtévesztő és
ezért is hozott be az a két
legnépszerűbb műsor eddig nagyobb
nézettséget mert egyhogy behozol ezekkel
mondom olyan embereket is akik akik
adnak a látványra is mondjuk még nem
hallgatnak podcastet mert egyszerűen
nincs arra igényük de azért simán leünek
és egy órát végignéznek mint mondjuk egy
tvében hogy végignéz néznek egy műsort
vagy netflixen megnéznének egy egy órás
műsort ez az egyik a a másik meg hogy
hogy azért nagyon befolyásolja a a
mögöttes algoritmikus világ az hogy mi
hogyan fut tehát én azért mondomatom
neked is mindig ugye a háttérben azért
sokat beszélgetünk erről hogy mi a titka
egy jó műsornak vagy mi mozdíthatja ki a
számokat a abból a stabil holdpontból
ahol a műsor van az az hogy hogy valami
olyan dolgot valami olyan csontot dobj
oda az algoritmusnak amire ő ráharaps
aztán onnantól már szépen látszik hogy
ível felfele na most ez a két műsor
hogyha ki kell mondjam ugye a az egyik
gyímesbe készült a másik gyergyó mellett
de tehát nagyon értékes beszélgetések de
de mondom a a a látványvilágát sorolnám
be hát az biztos hogy a látványvilága ez
m amikor először megláttam a a gyimesi
epizódot ahogy
kezdődött szó szerint napokig g
gondolkoztam azon hogy te jó ég mekkora
potenciál van a kezünkben mert valójában
a méia műhely kezében ezáltal énkem
fogalmam se volt hogy ilyet tudunk
csinálni mert a podcast az íy jóval
egyszerűbb ennél igen meg ide ide már
ugye bejön az is hogy hogy tényleg hogy
szabós amú is a háttérbe a jamink igen
hogy ő is ő is ugye rengeteget hozzátesz
ugye mindig a azok akik a kamer háta
mögött vannak nem látszanak de de más az
amikor mondjuk egy stúdióba arra figyel
hogy minden rendbe menjen és a
kreativitását azt max az első három
percbe tudja kiélni amikor a megnézi
hogy most egy kicsit sárgább legyen mint
utoljára a stúdióba de hogy körülbelül
ugyanenny ennyi még hogyha kimegyünk egy
ilyen helyre akkor ott azért már ú
meglátt egy vagányvágóképet ezt le tudom
fedni nem tudom én melyik gondolattal
tehát na ezek ezek mind hozzáadnak ahhoz
hogy ez ez robbanni tudjon és igen itt
itt már bejön az a képbe hogy hogy azért
van nekünk egy olyan is a kezünkben hogy
azért mégis csak a szakmánk és
és ez a podcastes dolog egyébként én
pont a napokban amikor tudtam hogy jövök
ide hozzád azon gondolkodtam így a
hasonlítgattam a szakmámat mindenfélével
amit én csinálok mi a szakmát mi a
szakmát hát nekem hogyha ha ugye mint a
olyan vicces hogy ha megfogsz egy
terméket a kauflandba akkor ugye van egy
ilyen törvény hogy a legnagyobb
alapanyagot tartalmazó dolgot kell
mindig előretedd tehát például meg
igen ez egy törvény na most hogyha én is
így kellene mondjam az összetevőimet
akkor egyértelműen a fényképezés van
legelő tehát hogy a mondjuk ebből élek
meg és nagyjából egy ilyen szerintem
ilyen 70-80%ban az időmet is ez veszi
hát a fotó meg a film mert azért sok
filmes projektünk is van és honnan is
kötöttünk ide ja igen hogy hogy nekünk
nekünk azért ez egy hatalmas nagy előny
hogy bár szűz volt a podcast világnak a
tere vagy témája de azért mi anno
egyetemen tanultunk arról hogy mi a hang
mi a kép mi a mikrofon mi a vágás
ismerjük a vágóprogramokat tehát hogyha
most valaki elkezd egy podcast műsort
felvenni nekünk már ott volt a kezünkben
az hogy amúgy is meg volt vásárolva a
vágóprogram amúgy is értünk hozzá amúgy
is tudjuk hogy h mi az a hangsáv mi az a
képisáv amúgy is tudjuk hogy kell
feliratozni tehát azért nyilván ez egy
hatalmas nagy előny volt az biztos é én
én nem mertem volna nekivágni így
podcastelni maga a maga a tartalom az az
egyszerűbb része nekem de az a
technológia ami körbevesz minket így a
fények meg kép meg meg mindenféle ez ez
ez tényleg hihetetlenül komplex számomra
így így most így kívülről nézve nyilván
meg lehet tanulni de hogy hogy tényleg
ha a szakmádnak a része akkor ez egy ez
egy nagy nagy segítség volt nekünk üüm
igen de ez egy időutá megfordul olyan
érdekes hogy ugye mindig az emberek
gondolkodnak azon hogy mennyit ad egy
szakmához a felszerelés vagy mennyit ad
a tehetség satöbbi most már azért
mindenki egyetért abban hogy bár az
elején ez jelenti a komplexitást hogy
miértessz hozza ismered-e a technikát
ismered-e a folyamatokat de azért ez egy
idő után úgyis megváltozik és úgyis a
tartalom lesz a fontos vagy az hogy meg
dolgozol a a témán mert például a
tehetség is egy ilyen dolog hogy én
nagyon ki merem azt jelenteni hogy kell
egy kicsi tehetség de egyébként lehet
lehet nagyokat alkotni úgy is hogy azt a
tehetséget is megpróbálod minél jobban
megtanulni vagy el saját hitel persze
persze tehát ez a fajta tévképzet hogy
úgy kell szüles tehetségesen ezt ezt ezt
én azt hiszem egy egy
manipulatív produktuma a világunknak
hogy nem az emberek ritkán születnek
nagy tehetséggel és legtöbbször viszont
kőkemény munkával csodálatos dolgokat
lehet elérni ahogy mi is egy az elmúlt
egy év ben látom rajtad és magamon is
hogy rengeteget tanultunk és és ki tudja
még mennyi mindent fogunk tudni tanulni
ja az biztos ez ez izigat engem a
legjobban tehát én például most
egyáltalán nem izgulok ezt nem mondhatom
el ezelőtt egy mennyi öt hónappal amikor
leültem az első pár forgatásra tényleg
izgultam és a galuska ott volt a torkom
nem fészettő most kicsit kijön belőlem
az hogy nem akarom én vezetni ezt a
podcastet de de például azon nem
gondolkodó gondolkodsz hogy tehát én
például ha azt érzem hogy tehát ha nem
én például jó akkor kezdjük onnan hogy
volt olyan műsorom hogy nem
izgultam túl lazára vettem és érzem is
hogy hogy nem adtam eleget bele nincs
benned egy ilyen lehet lehet hogy amiatt
izgulok hogy kéne izguljak nem nem tehát
hogy ébernek éber kell legyek ez fontos
az a fajta izgalom nem volt most bennem
tudtam hogy veled ülök le beszélgetni
tudtam hogy amúgy is beszélgetünk tehát
egy-egy beszélgetésünket is fel lehetne
venni hogyha ha valaki ott lenne tehát
mondjam úgy hogy egy gyakorlott partner
vagyunk és emiatt élvezem ezt a
beszélgetést hogy most olyan mélységekig
fogunk belemenni olyan komplexitásig
amelyig csak tudunk tehát a az
intellektuál intellektuális
határaain határait fogjuk súrolni
képzeld el hogy an mi amúgy ezért
kezdtük az én sztorim az röviden az hogy
fényképészként nagyon-nagyon közeli
kapcsolatot ápoltunk három négy öt másik
személlyel akik szintén fényképészek
voltak és mit csinálni egy fényképész
hétköznap hát vü a számítógép előtt és
utó munkázik és ez az utó munkázás egy
idő után már átvált egy olyan rutinnál
hogy hogy mellette podcastet tudok
hallgatni satöbbi sat többi tehát a mai
napig ezért vagyok én ekkora podcast
függő mint hallgató is mert mert nagyon
sok az az időm amikor tudok hallgatni na
de ezekkel a fényképészekkel azt vettük
észre hogy egyébként miért mi a francért
messengerezzünk és zökkentsen ki
folyamatosan azt hogy írogatunk hát
hívjuk fel egymást skype-on és úgy t el
körülbelül öt-h évünk nagyon durva de
tehát nagyon sok éven keresztül
skypeoltunk és már olyan rutinná vált
hogy amikor ott voltunk utómunkázni ha
ketten hárman is de szinte minden
délelőtt skype voltunk és egy adott
ponton valamikor ott 2000 x évben nem
tudom mikor volt a
podcastünk azt mondtuk hogy hát miért
nem veszük fel ezeket a beszélgetésüket
és így indult el az első podcastünk annú
igen hát ez sz és és emlékszem hogy
hallgattuk is azt a most már a a covidba
belecsúsztatok nem nem csúsz a covid
előtt volt ugye hát őszintén nem tudom
pontosan hogy azokat azok pontosan mikor
is voltak de nem nem nem a covidos
időszak volt assiszem akkor ott már
akkor már leálltatok hanem igen igen
igen aztán abbahagytuk mert rájöttünk
hogy nehéz összeegyeztetni úgy a
programot ahogy annó skypeon egyszerű
volt de
na jó térjünk vissza a műsorodra 24
epizód kiment és mellette még egy jó pár
ilyen live meg meg más formátumú
beszélgetés ha nem a nézettség az ami a
leginkább a a tehát bizonyos szempontból
a szerencse az algoritmus meg a vágás
meg a kép
minősége meg a a a látvány elemek azok
amik vonzzák a tekintetet ha nem ez
mutatja a azt hogy melyik a legjobban
sikerült epizódod akkor számodra melyik
az amit a legjobban élveztél szerinted
melyik az amelyik a legjobban siker ült
ami amit most így utólag így a
megemlíteniú hát ezt ezt ezt ezen néha
én is gondolkodom de de azért nem tudok
egyet se olyan konkrétan kiemelni mert
igazából mind tát nem most nyilván nem
azt mondom hogy mindegyik mert vannak az
én szememben nem annyira jól sikerült
dolgok vannak amik nagyon jól sikerültek
de ezek általában nem azért nem
sikerülnek jó mert nem tudom a vghhívott
az nem volt elég érdekes a té tmája mert
ugye ezt is beszéltük sokszó veled hogy
minden mindenkiből ki lehet hozni vagány
dolgokat nem azért mert mondjuk én nem
jöttem jó kérdésekkel vagy volt olyan
egyértelműen hogy azt éreztem hogy nem
tudtam azt kihozni belőle amit egyébként
tudok hogy ki lehetett volna hozni
belőle tehát ilyen is volt
ezinem azok állnak hozzám közelebb ahol
azt érzem hogy én is megtudtam rengeteg
új információt illetve van nekem egy
nagyon fontos fonalam ami ami mentén
most már próbálok minden egyes műsort
felépíteni és az az hogy minél
többet tehát az adott témáról minél
többet tudjunk átadni a közönségnek
annak a pár 100záz vagy pár ezer
embernek akik végighallgatják vagy a
jövőben nem tudom pár tízer vagy pár
100zázezer
mert én nagyon igyekszem annyira
általánosságban beszélgetni a témákról
hogy a az ne egy adott közösséget
szolgáljon csak ki vagy ne csak az ő
szakmáját szolgálja ki vagy ne csak egy
várost szolgáljon ki hanem hanem igenis
szolgálja ki azt a közönséget aki most
mondjuk c akkor pont a nőgyogyászati
témával foglalkozó epizódon jut eszembe
hogy az akit érdekel komolyabban hogy mi
is van egy nővel mi is van egy
születéssel egy egy
szüléssel de mit is kell mondjuk
csinálon egy apa ha lánya születik vagy
mit is kell megér egy apa a egyáltalán
az anyáról akkor azt
tudjuk szakmától és helytől és várostól
függetlenül átadni neki ezt az
információt és ebből próbálom mérlegelni
a a műsoraimat olyan szinten hogy ami
egy picit elmegy már ilyen ilyen
bulvárosba ilyen na igen é akkor a
férjed de hol ismerkedtél meg é jaj de
szép volt hogy nem tudom melyik hídon
megcsóoltátok először egymást meg
satöbbi nyilván ez is meg vagány meg ez
is egy szórakoztató dolog nem akarom
őket se egyáltalán semmilyen szintre
emelni vagy csökkenteni csak nekem nem
ez a célom üüm nekem az a célom akkor
érzem sikeresnek a műsort ha bejön
valaki mondjuk te bejössz a podcast
témába vagy az informatika témá vagy
valami és úgy ki tudom húzni belőled a
műsorokat hogy azt a közösség egy tehát
úgy álljon fel a podcast mellől hogy azt
érezze hogy ó na ez igen ma is tanultam
valamit igen és e ezt meg tudom
erősíteni hog például a legutolsó epizód
ugye erősíts meg hogy ez a
választásokkal kapcsolatos igen mire ez
már kimegy nem ez lesz az utolsó de igen
igenigen igen
igen az autóban hallgattuk meg a
feleségemmel julival és eszméletlen volt
eszméletlen volt tehát egyrészt alig
tudtuk abb hagyni nem is hagytuk abba
igazából csak megálltunk egy egy
szünetre és és és pont az a dilemma ami
bennünk volt hogy oké itt vannak a
választások fogalmam sincs hogy kire
kéne szavazni mármint nyilván hogy hogy
hogy hogy hogy van egy ötletem de hogy
hogy mélyebben nem ástam bele magam egy
egy pont arra volt szükségem hogy
valójában ti egy térképet rajzoltatok
egy egy alacsony felbontású térképet
hogy kábé melyik párttal mi a helyzet és
és és és ez hasznos volt tehát nem csak
hogy szórakoztató volt a a a vendéged
kivételesen jó volt de de emellett
nagyon hasznos is volt úgyhogy ezt meg
tudom erősíteni hogy hogy hogy az nekünk
egy olyan valami volt ami ami hogyha ha
nem lennénk ismerősök is szerintem már
csak amiatt feliratkoztam volna a
csatornádra na ehhez képest látod hogyha
a számokat nézem akkor ez eddig az egyik
leg nem tudom van ilyen tehát hogy
legnépszerűtlenebb vagy legkisebb
számokat generáló műsor nyilván azért
mert politikáruszó és az emberek a
politikától azért még mindig nem úgy
tekintenek a politikára ahogy szerintem
kellene én is nagy
nagy munkával és nagy vándorlással
kellett végigsétál azon az úton hogy
megértsem hogy a politika az miért tud
fontos lenni akarok is ezzel a hosszú
távon is minél többet foglalkozni de
látod például te nagyon hasznosnak
tartottad és mégis kevés számokat hozz
így van ez egy érdekesés ez ez ez azért
mert egyszerűen a mert ez a ez a jellege
ennek a témának vagy ez a ez a magával
hordozója most hogyha
nem tudom ebben a másfél órás politikai
műsorban azt osztottuk volna meg hogy
hogy nem tudom tudom is én valamilyen
botrányos nem tudom én milyen
nagy dolgokat
kiderítő érdekes vicces helyzet a
politikusokat nem tudom hülye helyzetbe
hozom nem tudom mi lett volna akkor
lehet hozzásegített volna ahhoz hogy még
több nézőt behozzon nem tudom ezzel még
én is kísérletezem
de azt tudom hogy hogy nekem nekem mi a
célom ezzel és és és azon kell tovább
menni és igen nagy dilemma volt
egyébként a meghívottam is nagyon
kíváncsi volt arra hogy hogyan fog
produkálni ez a műsor és mondtam neki is
hogy ne ne nézzük azért annyira a
számokat mert
tényleg ezt szerintem úgy lehet például
a politikában is fejleszteni a a
bázisodat vagy a nézőközönségedet úgy
hogyha tényleg és mindenben a podcaste
podcastezésben is hogy folyamatosan hozd
a tartalmakat és nem csak így néha
bedobsz egyet kettő csakk most nem lehet
arra számítani mert ez is nagyon fontos
a nézőknek hogy hogy tudják hogy hogy te
ott leszel két hetente és azért úgy
érzem már hogy van egy olyan kemény mag
ami ami nagyon jól esik és nagyon
örvendek annak hogy azok a nevek nagyon
sok helyen felbukkannak ha kommentként
ha lájként ha valahol ez kábé hány
személy szerinted fú az a az a vicces
hát
én megmerem kockáztatni és nagyon-nagyon
bízom benne hogy azért legalább egy egy
50-en már vannak de nem tudom
ez csak egy ilyen
remélem ha nem tudom azért nem tudom
mert és egy kicsit ez bosszant is és
ezutan is üzenem a nézőknek hogy hogy az
hogy most valamit lájkolunk megosztunk
vagy satöbbi az azért tehát főleg a lá
vagy a valamilyen fajta kifejezése annak
hogy helló itt voltam az azért nagyon
fontos főleg így nekünk az elején mert
mert pont hogy pont hogy mi is kellene
érezzük azt hogy hogy van- erre
egyáltalán igény vagy egy kicsit tudod
mindig a nézők is nem mondom azt hogy
kell befolyásolják mert azért te kell
öntsd hogy mit akarsz amellett nagyon
erősen kitartsál de lehet ha tudod jön
egy ilyen visszajelzés hogy hát azért a
végén a műsor utolsó 10 percében azért
jó lett volna egy kicsit beszélni arról
is hogy tudod csak akkor ilyenekből
lehet azért fejlődni és na arra akartam
kihugadni hogy hány lehet ilyen kemény
mag azért nem lehet ezt felmérni mert
nemrég voltam egy eseményen ahol három
olyan személlyel is beszélgettem akiket
nem ismertem hallgatták eddig szinte
minden egyiket minden egyes epizódomat
végig azt mondták hogy végigallgatták a
24-ből 15-öt biztosan nem ismertem őket
és egyszerűen nem tudtam sose láttam még
az ő nevüket sehol se kommentbe se ilyen
nem tudom megosztásként vagy valahol
igen szóval lehetnak vannak olyan
emberek akik kemény magba tartoznak de
egyszerűen se se nem mint patronáló a
patreonon sem sehol nem látom az ő
nevüket apropó patrion kicsit mesélné
róla hogy egyrészt mi ez a mi ez a
platform hogyan működik és hogy hányan
támogatnak ebben most milyen jó lenne ha
lenne neked is mert akkor tudnám egy
kicsit promózni hogy téged is tudnak
segíteni a sác igen hát lehet majd de
lehet mire ez kijön ez az epizód arra
megcsinálod igen
hát ugye most nem akarok tényleg annyira
komplexen belemenni mert egy kicsit ez
is a hibám hogy mindent ilyen nagyon
elülről az legelejéről akarok kezdeni a
amikor még kipattintatták a kőből az
első szerszámot de
ugye foglalkozunk mi ezzel nagyon sokat
hogy hogyan is áll egy egy podcast főleg
én elég sok munkaórát fektetek abba hogy
legyen egy ilyen kisokos
és ennek van egy fajta a podcastnek van
egy fajta
monetizálása amit egy idő után muszáj
valamilyen formában kihasználj
mert mert azért meg kéne egy idő után
nyilván mint az ember bármit is csinál
ebbe az életbe azért valamiből el kell
tartsa a családját valamiből ki kell
fizesse azokat az embereket akik tényleg
hozzájárulnak az idejük k ebbe a dologba
és akkor vannak bizonyos monetizációs
lehetőségek hogy hogy lehet egy
podcastből pénzt csinálni pont és az
egyik az az hogy ilyen közösségi
finanszírozásként valami olyan felületet
indítassz el ahol az emberek be tudnak
szállni ugyanúgy ahogy a netflixbe
beszállnak ugyanúgy ahogy a nem tudom
mit mondjak kifizetik a gázszámlájukat
mert ki kell fizessék minden hónapban
ugyanúgy a csakab bajnak is vagy a
navigátor podcastnek is ki tudj tudják
fizetni azt az összeget havonta amit
egyébként ők dönthetik- el hogy az
mennyi legyen és akkor a patreon is egy
olyan felület ahol te létrehozhatsz
csomagokat azt mondod hogy neked van egy
4 eur-s csomagod neked van egy 1000
eur-s csomagod és akkor az emberek
eldönthetik hogy ide feliratkoznak és
akkor itt
igazából hát mondjuk azt hogy
fizethetnek de ez egy kicsit olyan
furcsa hogy fizethetnek mert itt azért
nem épp az van hogy te valamiért fizetsz
hanem ez egy kicsit úgy valahogy a
fizetésnek egy olyan másfajta
megközelítés mint amikor a haverok
összedobnak valami pénzt azért igen igen
igen tehát ez egy olyan közösségi
finanszírozás igazából ahol ahol te
megkéred az embereket hogy neked vannak
bizonyos költségeid és ha ők úgy
gondolják hogy ez a saját megélhetésük
mellett ez neked vagyis ez ez nekik még
belefér ez nagyon fontos hogy nem akarom
sose azt mondani hogy ó hát figyelj hát
nézzek kaptál egy csomó vagány tartalmat
amit tervezek olyan tartalmakat amit
lehet egy képzés során nem tudom 2000
euróér tudna megvásárolni egy bostoni
nem tudom én milyen képzőtő most nyilván
nem lesz olyan minőségű satöbbi de hogy
ezt ingyen fogja megkapni ha ő úgy érzi
hogy neki belefér hogy nem tudom ha nem
is patreonon de egyszeri támogatásként
utaljon ezért 10-20 dollárt akkor azt
most mennyi jön be havonta
hát hát ez ilyen nagyon gyorsan változó
mert lehet neki ilyen egyszeri támogat
atások volt már ilyen is van a
youtube-on ilyen super tanks gomb amire
ha rákattint akkor küldhet 10 dollárt 20
dollárt 5 dollárt ez nagyon változó nem
tudom ezt most pontosan megmondani és
őszintén nem is nagyon követem még
annyira számon mert
egő mé bentartjukk a misztikus ködöt
azért hogy eloszlassuk a a hallgatók
számára itt nem 1000 eurókrólá ja nem
nem ja nyilván el elmondom azt tehát
egyelőre még bentartjuk mi ezeken a
felületeken azért is mert egyelőre még
nem látjuk értelmét ezeket kivenni plusz
még mi is keressük azt a
azt a formát ahol ezt egyáltalán mi
normálisan
hivatalosan leadózva úgymond el tudjuk
köteni tehát hogy röviden kimondva és
nem titkolok semmit
nem hoztunk még létre erre
egyesületet de akarunk addig viszont
bent tartsuk tehát ott van még a
youtube-nál vagy ott van még a
patreonnál ez a pénz mert
addig egyáltalán nem akarunk azzal
foglalkozni míg mindent tisztán és
normálisan nem csinálunk de ez olyan
kicsit olyan kényelmes helyzetbe is rak
minket hogy addig amíg nincs a számlámon
pénz addig igazából nem is kell aggódjak
amiatt hogy az állambácsi esetleg
haragudhat-e rám de hogy mennyi nyilván
nem tehát hogyha most számszerűsíteni
kellene akkor ilyen nem tudom ezt fogom
részben beleváni igen akkor ilyen ilyen
1000 lej fele haladhatunk egy év után
tehát
hogy ami egyébként ha le akar osztani
arra hogy itt milyen produkciós
költségek mentek végbe akkor ez egy
nevetséges dolog tehát hogy tehát nekem
havonta 1200 lbe kerül most a az én
produkciós költségem úgyhogy e csak úgy
hasonlítva mondom hogy hogy ez tényleg
nem egy jelképes összeg nyilván nem is
azért csináljuk hogy hogy hogy
profitábilis legyen habár nem lenne
rossz mert az adna bizonyos fokú
szabadságot de gondolom hogy még ki kell
ér megszabadíttan felidőt én ezen én
ezen próbálok azért egy kicsit harcolni
hogy megértsék az emberek hogy hogy én
is minél jobban abból a 80%-os
fotózásból le tudok majd még egy picit
meg az egyéb témáimból is egy picit le
tudok faragni nem fogom elhagyni a
fotózást valószínű szinte soha de hogy
mondjuk hajlandó lennék leforogni akár
50%-ra is azt a fotózást ühüm és azt a
és azt a 30%-ot azt most nem mindent
számokban mérek mert nincsen nekem ilyen
hogy na ennyi kell havontas azt ha nem
szerzem meg akkor nek nekem senki ne
zavarjon nem ez valószínű egy idő után
megint ugye vagy folyamatosan
változásban van ez a szám de de időm
szabadulna feel hogyha itt valahol
valamilyen formában megtér persze meg
valahol ki kell érdemeljük ezt tehát
hogy meg kell végig kell járjuk azokat a
lépcsőfokokat ameddig eljutunk oda mint
a nagy nagyobb podcaserek nem is tudom
hogy el fogunk-e jutni vagy legalábbis
én el fogok-e tudni jutni de de ha már
egyből sikeres lenne ez túl túl nagy
teher lenne szerintem rajtam nem ezt
ahhoz tudom a legjobban hasonlít annó
mikor az első gyerekünk született akkor
sokat beszélgettünk arról hogy az apának
a kilenc hónapos terhességben mi tud
lenni a szerepe és mindig úgy elkacagtuk
hogy hogy hát azért kell az a kilenc
hónap mert hogy az apa is egyfajta tehát
nem csak a nő készülfel mindenféle
szempontból hanem az apának is időt ad
abban hogy hogy mire megszületik a
gyerek tudatosuljon benne hogy tényleg
jön egy gyerek tehát most képzeld el
hogy 24 évesként vagy 25 évesként vagy
manapság nem tudom 30
évesként vagy egy házasságban és egyszer
csak leesne egy csecsemő tehát hogy na
most a podcastet is valahol hogyha ehhez
kéne hasonlítsam nem tudom ez mennyire
volt durva hasonlat de most képzeld el
hogy egyszer csak leesne egy ilyen két
milliós követői bázissal rendelkező
csatorna amit követnek a nagyvilágba és
angol nyelvű igen meg egyáltalán
megbírnák valójában mindenki kap
ütéseket is meg kedves szavakat is és
tudom hogy te amúgy én is de de amúgy te
is a negatív kommentekre figyelsz és
most képzeld el hogy egy-egy ilyen
anonymus félpszichopata troll így
be bekiabál anélkül hogy valami igaza
lenne el tudnánk-e bírni 2 millió
követőbázis mellett 5000
ilyen kommentet és általában azokal hogy
a normális komment vagyis
normális pozitív visszajelzések sokszor
elmaradnak tehát az emberek nem írnak
annyira kommentát hogy de szuper volt
vagy nem tudom inkább a negatívum az ami
felhangosodik és amikor 50-50%ban látsz
negatívat is pozitívat akkor hajlamos
vagy arra gondolni hogy ez ez azért elég
rossz volt e ez ez az epizód kialakult
az emberekben manapság szánjunk egy
percet gyorsan erre is hogy kialakult az
emberekben manapság az hogy nem tudom
mintha szégyen lenne ljkolni vagy vagy
kommentelni vagy bármi de igazából én
ezen próbálok a saját legalább a kemény
magomat azt a pár
embert tehát egyfajta tanításként
elmagyarázni nekik és és és akár itt is
kimondva hogy az nem szégyen leírni a
véleményedet és nagyon sokat segít
mindenféle szempontból a
tartalomgyártónak is belőlem lehet hogy
azért is jön egy ilyen fajta érzés mert
a például a fotóim azok egyértelműen
maga a fotózás az egyértelműen egy olyan
szakma ahol folyamatosan bombáznak
visszajelzésekkel tehát nem tud úgy
lejárni egy munka vagy egy átadás vagy
egy semmi nem tud úgy leállni a
fotózásban hogy utána ne
rohamozzon meg téged egy hatalmas nagy
adag visszajelzés bármilyenféle
szempontból ha negatív akkor azért ha
pozitív akkor meg nyilván azért és és ez
kell most az hogy az emberek nem akarnak
az interneten kinyilvánítani semmilyen
véleményt vagy nem akarnak lájkolni ezt
is megértem de azért képzeljék el azt és
azt is szoktam sokszor belefoglalni a
gondolataimba hogy ha nem is küldesz 10
lejt patreonon de azzal már hatalmasat
segítesz hogyha leírod a véleményedet
vagy lájkolod vagy vagy megosztod ha nem
is nyilvánosan de legalább beteszed a
családi csoportodba vagy a haveri
körödbe és azt mondod hogy gyerekek ezt
hallgassátok végig nekünk ezek ezek
hatalmas nagy segítség ez így van meg a
világunk változik tehát hogy aminek még
nekifogtunk még nincs nagy kultúrája itt
de nyugaton a podcast kultúra az az az
hihetetlenül fejlett és és virágzik
tehát az egyik legnagyobb csoda számomra
most az amerikai választások
hogy trump ilonm és vence is elment joe
roganhez joe rogan a a a hallgató
kedvéér mondom ő a podcast atja ő
indította el ezt a a podcast kultúrát
még még pedig úgy pont ahogy mondtad
hogy eleinte csak felvették a hangot
leültek beszél két ember leült
beszélgetni olyan témákról amik számukra
érdekesek és felvették a hangot és
valahol feltöltötték valahova egy
internetre ekkor még nem az a fajta
internetes világ volt ami most hogy
minden elérhető és és ezek a közösségi
platformok ezek
nem voltak kiépülve hanem a épülőben
voltak és egy idő után vagy két év után
jött rá joe rogan hogy hogy vagy vannak
akik hallgatják ezt meglepődőtt ő se
számított erre ő ő csak feltöltötte oda
hogy hogy ha valaki esetleg hallgatná de
talán inkább mint hogyha archívumként
oda feltöltette mag nának innen indult
ki ez a podcast kultúra is fejlődött és
a és és és eszméletlenül hog hova
fejlődött tehát én most az amerikai
választásokat elég közelről követtem az
elmúlt egy évben szinte hát hát nem
mondom napi szinten de de heti szinten
rászántam azért időt hogy meghallgassam
ezeket a a a jelölteket vive ramaswamit
meg meg meg trumpot követtem meg a másik
oldalról bident is követtem kamalát csak
azután
miután miután miután lett
viszont érzem hogy valami változás van
tehát abban a pillanatban miha egy trump
elment joe
rogan műsorába egyszerűen hihetetlen
volt tehát egy óra után már nem tudom
hány millió nézettsége volt és és 24 óra
múlva tizenvalamennyi millió és 72 óra
múlva pedig 30 valamennyi most
legutoljára amikor néztem egy egy hetel
volt a választások előtt 50 valamennyi
milliós nézettsége volt na most nyilván
sokan rákattintanak és nem nézik végig
nyilván mert egy három órás műsor volt
de azért én végignéztem vagy
végigallgattam pontosabban és és el
tudom képzelni hogy hogy azért a
választó
közül lehet hogy volt jó pár milliónyi
választó aki meghallgatta és lehet hogy
jó pár millióan megváltoztatták a
véleményüket trumpról mert azért három
órán keresztül hallgatni valakit
pontosan ezt a személyes oldalt hozza be
hogy hogy hogy joe rogan elmondta hogy
hogy neki a célja az volt hogy csak
beszéljenek mindegy hogy miről de
beszéljenek mert a beszélgetés közben
kibontakozódik a a a az énye a másik
személynek lehet látni azt a azt a
személyes oldal át amit amúgy senki nem
látna hogyha ha ha mind ilyen virális
videóként egy-egy percet töltenek fel
egy egy olyan pillanatról amikor éppen
ideges vagy olyan pillanatban amikor
éppen nem tudom cinikus vagy valakit
kikacag vagy valami akkor el lehet ezzel
ferdíteni valakinek a képét így a a a a
közszférába de hogyha három órán
keresztül valakivel beszélgetsz akkor
kialakul egy olyan képr róla hogy persze
egy-egy mondata a kemény más mondata nem
annyira kemény egy egy ilyen egyveleg
kialakul és ilyen az ember valójában egy
egyveleg vagyunk én sem vagyok csak
ilyen vagy csak olyan ahogy te sem
nagyon színesek vagyunk és és a podcast
az egy ilyen ilyen közeg na most
szerintem a választást nem mondom hogy
eldöntötte de de de de egy
hihetetlen tektonikai mozgást okozott
így a a választók között valójában elon
musk vance és és trumpnak a a a az
interjúja vagy 10 órát tartott tehát
összesen hogyha most minden platformot
összeszámolunk lehet hogy y 200 millió
200 milliós nézettségel van ez ezek
eszméletlen számok a ha ha most azt
nézem hogy hogy főműsoridőben a a a
cnn-nek például lehet hogy van vagy 1,6
millió nézettsége vagy vagy kt millió
nézettsége joe rogannek egyedül van egy
személyben ti milliós nézettsége ez az
egyik a másik pedig az hogy cala nem
akart elmenni joe rogannek a műsorába ez
már elmond valamit mert mert joe rogan
szétszedte volna valójában azáltal hogy
leülsz valakivel beszélgetni még akkor
is hogyha bármiről is beszél
két óra e és ezek az ő gondolataik
voltak valólyan elon musk és joe rogan
beszélgetett erről hogy kábé a két óra
utáni harmadik órában van az amikor az
ember teljesen szétesik tehát addig
addig játssza amit amit azt a szerepet
amit magának kiosztott és utána pedig
szétesik darabokra és ez egy veszélyes
dolog és szerintem tudatosan mondták
neki kamalának hogy ne menjl el ha ha ha
meg akarod nyerni ezt a választást ne
menj oda mert ebben véged és nem ment
oda és és bizonyos szempontból ez is az
oka szerintem hogy az emberek azt
mondták hogy oké hát akkor egy
hiteltelen valaki számunkra hogyha nem
mer joe rogannel leülni ha tetszik ez az
epizód akkor kérlek ne felejtsetek el
feliratkozni a csatornánkra osszátok meg
valamint hagyjatok egy kommentet ezzel
nagyban segítitek a munkánkat
ühüm
no hát abba abba nem nem tudok mivel
hogy nem tudok ezér nem is merek vagy
nem is akarok nagyon semmiféle
szempontból bármit kijelenteni hogy
tényleg mi az ami döntött vagy sem mert
nyilván ez egy annyira komplex nehéz és
sok összetevős dolog kezdve attól hogy a
billengő államokban is mi történt mi nem
történt kinek mennyire erős a kampánya
kinek milyen a mozgósítása ki utána
hogyan és mire tudta esetleg ezeket a
podcastes műsorokat is
felhasználni meg ez most körülbelül nem
tudom a szerintem az 5%-ka volt amit
elmondtam mer emellett még van 95% olyan
ami még hozzájárulhat
egyá íg hozzátartozik a podcast is igen
de de csak arra akarok általánosságba
ráfordulni hogy viszont azt szerintem ki
lehet jelenteni és valahol van is bennem
egy ilyen egy ilyen sunyi kis boldogság
abból a szempontból hogy tényleg ki
lehet azt jelenteni hogy innentől kezdve
egy más fejezet kezdődik a a podcast
iparban az hogy ez mennyire podcast ipar
vagy sem vagy mennyire jönnek be mert én
is kicsit úgy félek néha hogy akkor most
ez podcast vagy egyéb műsor vagy nem
vagy vagy honnantól nem lesz podcast
tehát hogyha már elkezdek vágóképeket
rádobálni a beszélgetésre vagy bevágunk
ide nem tudom én milyen statisztikákat a
fejem fölé vagy alá akkor az még
podcasté nem tudom egyelőre ezt így
meghatározni de hogy ez a fajta tartalom
most már egyre jobban el fog indulni az
biztos és nagyon kíváncsian várom azt
hogy mikor burjánzik le ez felénk is
ide a környékünkre mert én mert mert
régebb folyamatosan azt hallottuk hogy a
hogy például a politikusok ha már róla
róluk beszélünk nem nagyon mentek ilyen
helyekre pont amiatt hogy
sokat és most azért legyünk őszinték
hogyha most leülsz egy nem tudom én
honnan érkező polgármester bácsikával
akkor azért el tud sülni nagyon szépen
is de azért nagyon-nagyon csúnyán is el
tudna visel sülni egy egy ilyen
beszélgetés de viszont egy idő után
szerintem itt is bele lesznek ők ebbe
kényszerítve és már vannak is enre
mozgalódások elég keményen egyébként
romániában is tehát hogyha megnézzük a
román
hát nem is nevesebb de hogy nagy
csatornákat azért azért most már itt is
a jelöltek elég szépen eljárnak ilyen
helyekre és ott azért kiderülnek egy óra
alatt olyan válaszok tehát hogyha most
itt nem tudom nézzük simionnak is a a
mondatait hogy ő miket mond ki
tehát arra akarok kiukadni hogy ez ez ez
szerintem nekünk mint embereknek jó
lesz viszont ők is biztos hogy fejlődni
fognak ilyen téren tehát akkor igen azt
mondják hogy négy év múlva aki indul
választásra az az is azt is figyelembe
kell vegye például amerikába is hogy jó
jó gyerekek most már lejárt ez az idő
hogy mi ilyen kirakunk egy nagy plakátot
és ne rólad készül 300 darab ilyen 20
másodperces re egy kampányba és azokot
betanulod és profin és a szemedet hogy
mozgatod lejárt ez az idő következő
kampányra te fel kell készüljél úgy is
hogy te ilyen három órás beszélgetéseket
is le tudjá csakor lehet mármint lehet
készülni de nem tudsz manipulatívan
felkészülni egy három órás beszélgetésre
na ez lesz tudod az érdekes az hogy hogy
mennyire tehát az hogy az hogy ez is tud
egy valamilyen formában manipulatív
lenni szerintem tud
de de nyilván itt lesz már azzal a játék
hogy hogy egy egy néző mit tud leszűrni
belőle és az a másik személynek meg meg
a meg a műsorvezetőnek is mi az a
kvalitása amivel el tudja úgy terelni
azt a beszélgetést hogy az hogy az olyan
legyen hogy a néző is érezze az
őszinteséget vagy az igazságot vagy a
meghívottnak mik azok az erősségei
amivel é tudja terelni az adott témát
mert itt is nagyon sok hatalmas nagy a a
skála abban hogy valaki egy témát hogyan
tud elvinni úgy hogy az nem én én nem
hiszem én azt hiszem hogy a a a nézők
nem nem buták szóval hogyha a a meghívót
összejátszik a a a meghívóval nem ilyen
tehát hogyha hogy hogyha ha ez egy mű
valami lesz egyből észreveszik nem ilyen
szempontból csak most is látjuk azt
tudod hogy hogy képzelj el most a
fejedbe két interjút a interjú 10 percig
tart feltesznek neki a riporterek
kérdéseket és egyértelműen érződik hogy
ki tér előtte előle tehát nem nem érzed
hogy tehát vagyis bocsánat egyértelműen
érzed hogy ő kitért ez a válasz alól
vagy b interjw ugyanez a 10 perces
ö
kérdezfelelek csak úgy kér úgy tér ki a
válasz alól hogy a nézőknek már nem csak
10%-a vagyis bocsánat nem 90%-a veszi
észre hogy kitért hanem csak 40 és ott
más sokat számított nem tudom mennyire
érted nem nem nem tehát hogy j akkor itt
ezt kivágjuk é még egyszer elmondom
tehát ha van két ugyanolyan interjú
amiben a kérdező feltesz kérdéseket és
van két interjú alany két politikus igen
az egy egyik az nagyon egyértelműen
kitér a válaszok alól vagy mellől és a
nézőknek 90%-a érezni fogja hogy te ez
kitért a válasz ez nem akart válaszolni
satöbbi a másik alany az annyira profi
hogy úgy tér ki a válaszadásból hogy
csak a nagyon wi fülűek veszik észre
hogy ó ez kitért egyébként nem érzi azt
mert hogy válaszolt is de nem is de
behozott egy olyan témát amit lehet őt
jobban érdekli és el is felejtette a
kérdést tehát hogy ennek is meglesz a
művészete mert ilyen az emberiség és az
elmúlt pont pont ez a szép benne
szerintem hogy hihetetlenül unalmas lesz
egy podcast amikor feltesznek egy
kérdést és egy olyan választ adsz amikor
a végén az volt az érzésed hogy én ezt
nem értem mert pedig az van hogy hogy
aki aki őszinte éleseszű és egy egy
harcos mentalitással egy komplex
problémának nekimegy az érdekesen
izgalmasan tud beszélgetni egy egy
problémáról úgy hogy érthető is legyen a
másik személy számára akkor felteszem
másképp a kérdést gyere játszodozzunk
még e jó azt mondom és most nyilván nem
kell válaszolni csak direkt azért fogok
egy ilyen témát behozni hogy hogy
érezzük a súlyát én most megkérdezem
tőled én vagyok a műsorvezető te vagy a
a a meghívott és megkérdezem tőled
mondjuk hogy te figyelj megtudtam hogy a
családodban valaki nem tudom én
alkoholista igen és légyszíves egy
kicsit mesélj errő mondjuk ennyi a
kérdés és akkor benned van egy fajta nem
tudom nem akarod elmondani fájmos neked
túl mély a seb nem tudom bármi vagy
egyszerűen azt érzed hogy ennek a
beszélgetésnek most nincs itt a ebben a
ez a téma a helye és akkor mit tudsz
csinálni vagy azt mondod hogy bocsi
erről nem szeretnék beszélni nyilván ez
az
egyik ez lenne az egyik legkorrektebb
válasz de egy kampányban nem fogja senki
ezt mondani mert akkor azzal lehet totál
elássa magát és akkor mit tudsz csinálni
megpróbálsz illedelmesen erről a témáról
úgy beszélni hogy há amúgy nem értek
egyet az első versel
jó csak hogy csak hogy megpróbálsz erről
a témáról úgy beszélni hogy hogy akkor
most valamit megpróbálsz elmondani de
inkább arra tereled a hangsúlyt hogy te
most nem akarsz erről beszélni vagy vagy
mit csinálsz és ezzel fognak a
politikusok igazából játszani és ebbe
fejlődni hogy tudják a gyengepontjaikat
mert a háttérben 300 ember azon dolgozik
hogy minden egyes kérdésre neki legyen
millió egy válasza és ez nagy nagy
szinteken így működik valljuk be akkor
meg
lesznek neked olyan félórás blokkjaid
amiben ezzel a témával úgy tudsz
játszadozni hogy az minél kevesebb kárt
okozzon nos ez ez az én hipotézisem hogy
az roppant unalmas lesz ez a fajta
manipulatív játék mert az emberek
nagyon-nagyon figyelmesek tehát ha
megnézed a kommenteket nem a mi
podcastünknek a mert abból kevés van de
egy egy egy népszerű adásnak a
kommentjeit tűpontosan olyan
véleményeket fogalmaznak meg hogy hogyha
maga a a a meghívott manipulatív tegyük
fel de nagyon kedves vagy vagy akármi
érződik az hogy csomó negatív komment
hogy most elkerülte meg sö igen csak az
nagyon tehát hogyha hogyha arányaban
nézed azt se felejtsd el hogy tehát most
rengeteg a komment és rengeteg a
tűpontos észrevétel de a nézőszámhoz
képest az még mindig kevés tehát hogyha
mondjuk van van 100 millió megtekintés
egy videón és alatta van 300 komment
azért azért érted nagyon sokan megnézik
páran kommentelnek és ez így le és páran
felszavaznak kommenteket tehát hogy hogy
nem nem lehet hogy ő nem ír de beleolvas
az első így egyébként azz érdekes hogy
nagyon nagyon fejlődik annak is a a
kultúrája hogy egyébként a kommenteket
is nagyon olvassák ez ez az vagány engem
is érdekel megnyugtat az hogy nem csak
én hallottam valamit abban a videóban
hanem tényleg ott volt és szinte egy
egyszer se kell csalódjak abba hogy ha
valamit én éreztem és elkezdek
beleolvasni sőt még a kommentekből
sokszor tanulok is vannak dolgok amiket
úgy meg se tudtam fogalmazni és akkor
egy-egy frappáns megfogalmazá valaki
megpróbálja nagyon-nagyon frapppánsan
megfogalmazni hogy mi történt ott és
akkor ezren felszavazzák és rájövök arra
hogy tényleg igaza volt tehát valójában
ez egy ilyen kollaboráció a a a a a a
vendég a a
a host mind angolul jut eszembe hát a
műsorvezető én is én is keresem ennek a
magyar megfelelzzóval a műsorvezető a
vendégnek a a kollaborációja és
valójában utána életre kell és ennél még
szebb a dolog mert valójában utána
kivágják a videókat lesznek t 10 perces
formátumok lesznek resek amik ilyen 30
másodpercek és és egy csomó tehát
gyakorlatilag életre kell az egész és
amikor az a legszebb elküldtem egy
videót neked amikor dave rubin beszél az
ő podcastjében amibe bevág egy olyan
podcastet amikor elon musk
és
és na a most nem jut eszembe az
újságírónak a neve neked eszedbe jute
nem mindjárt megkérdezzük
samut igen szóval most nem j eszembe
dave dave ruan beszél egy olyan
podcastről
amiben amiben elon musk beszélget azzal
a riporterrel amiben arról beszélnek
hogy joe rogan hogyan beszélt joe
trumpalüm és tehát wow ez olyan mint az
inception az a film hogy az álomban ott
az álom amben ott van az álom és
valójában a kommentek is erről szólnak
és és egy egy pezsgő közösségnek a tagja
leszel ami egy komplex témát körbejár
mindenféle szem
hí kommentek jelennek meg és az aki
viszont őszintén csinálja az viszont
hietetlenül népszerű leszz képest igen
igen azt az kell tudni én mostz
ördögügyvég szerepként azért így a másik
oldalt azt azt próbálom most én tudod
egy kicsit mindig ilyen
negatívabb
hyehát
uge ne emeljünk ki vagy ne nevezzünk meg
egyetlen országot sem de ugye nagyon sok
nagy politikum azt a azt tudja játszani
hogy kitol a médiába olyan dolgot ami
elég nagy ferdítés
utána kiderül hogy az nem biztos hogy
igaz volt nyilván aki benne szerepel az
bepereli vagy helyreigazítást kér
satöbbi de egyértelműen mérik azt hogy
én inkább kitolok valami fél igazságot
azzal elérek az én bázisomba vagy
esetleg billegő embereknél olyan dolgot
amit el akartam érni de utána már a
helyreigazítást már nem éri el az
embereket már nem tudja meg senki de az
vagy az a helyireigazítás már nem ér el
azokhoz emberekhez
akikhez az előző elét de figyelj ez volt
a tévés világ amikor a produkciós
költség olyan vil hát ez az internetes
világ nem ez az internetes világ tehát
ezt csinálják ma a a sajtó azt akartam
mondani hogy a podcast pont ennek az
ellenkezőjé tehát egy egy ellenkező
tendenciát veszek észre ahol egy
személynek akkora hatalma lesz mint egy
tvtársaságnak mint például j
és mi nem vagyunk még ott erdélyben és
romániában de most képzeld el hogy eddig
milyen tehát most józs
leviről kijön egy cikk hogy pedofil
képeket kaptak a laptopodon és akkor ez
nem igaz amúgy a hallgató legalábbis én
nem tudok róla és és akkor persze te
felmegy a pumpa benned és akkor
elkezdesz körbenézni ez ki ki honnan jön
ez a forrás egy hét eltelik addig már a
reputációdat lerombolta az emberek
elkezdenek gyanakodni és akkor mit
csináltál volna 10 évvel ezelőtt amikor
vagy öt évvel ezelőtt amikor még az
kezedben nem volt semmi versusz most
amikor a csakab bajon tegyük fel leülsz
és leülünk két órán keresztül
beszélgetni erről hogy ez mit okozott az
életedbe van-e valóság alapja
meghallgatják ott is és akkor
gyakorlatilag már van egy védekezési
lehetőség neked a kisembernek cak csak
két nagyon fontos dolog már megtörtént
aminek ugyanaz a hatása mint egy nagy
médiumnak vagy egy nagy újságnak vagy a
nagy tévnek az egyik probléma ami már
megtörtént az az hogy már belekerülök
egy olyan magyarázkodásba vagy egy olyan
helyzetbe amit már egy bizonyos körben
helyrehozni nem nagyon fogok tudni vagy
nagyon nehezen mert az ahogy én leülök a
csakabajra és elkezdek erről beszélgetni
az már nem fog olyan szinten elérni mint
mondjuk egy egy random cikk arról ahol a
címszó vagyis a címmondatba az volt hogy
józsa leventének megkaptak valamit a
leptopján f írónál több ez az egyik a
másik meg az hogy nincsen mindenkinek a
kezében sajnos ez ez a nyilvánosság és
pont nemrég volt egy futás
alkalmával egy nagyon jó beszélgetésem
valakivel akinek pont a végén elkacaktuk
a hogy hogy úgy futottunk le másfél órát
hogy igazából egyszer se gondoltunk a
futásra végig ilyen nagyon-nagyon
intenzíven agyi munka is volt nem csak
testi mert végig beszélgettük és pont
erről beszélgettünk hogy hogyha
valakivel egy egy egy egy olyan
helyzetben levő emberrel akinek mit
tudom lehet facebookja sincs lehet nem
is internetezik
az ismerősség köre egy ilyen nagyon kis
buborék ők egyébként elmennek minden nap
ledolgozzák a nyolc óráikat hazamennek
kevés az ismeretségük satöbbi satöbbi ha
egy olyannal történik egy ilyen probléma
sokkal sokkal de lehet nem is tud nyúlni
egy ilyen nyilvánossághoz mint nekünk
ami van a kezünkben úgyhogy úgyhogy én
azért mindig még úgy vagyok vele hogy
hogy egy kicsit ilyen saját magammal
szemben ilyen megpróbálni konklúziót is
vonni ebből a gondolatból hogy hogy a
politikusok léteztek ezelőtt több 100
évvel is akkor azokkal az eszközökkel
dolgoztak amelyik voltak mikor megjelent
az újság akkor oda kellett fejlődjenek
hogy megjelent az újság amikor megjelent
a tév akkor oda fejlődtek n n8 12 év
alatt ahova fejlődtek megjelent az
internet totál átalakult tehát én nekem
vannak olyan gyerekkori emlékeim hogy
átunk mi a kapuba és a politikusok 20an
felvonultak az utcán és osztogatták a
pixelt tehát e sok udvarhelyi emlékezhet
ilyen kampányokra most nyilván itt is
nem megem nevezve na most képzelde
azokat a politikusokat ha irtelen lett
volna egy internet tehát hogy kellett az
az idő hogy felvegyék na most látszik mi
zajlik az interneten egy kampányba és
valószínű hogy a következő kampányban
már fog érződni azt is az is hogy hogy a
podcastet is hogyan használják ki nem
tudom de hogy de hogy látva ezeket a
számokat tuti hogy a hatalmas nagy
stábok dolgozni fognak azon is hogy mire
tudják kihasználni ezt a podcastet jóra
is de lehet ha rosszra is én nagyon
kíváncsi vagyokog rossra ki fogják-e
tudni használni mert valójában arról
szól ez hogy egy nagy auden audiencia
elét tárják a gondolataikat na most ha
az manipulatív abban reménykedhetnek
hogy elég jól tudják manipulálni a a
környezetüket és lehet hogy lehet hogy
valamilyen sikereket el fognak érni de
egyszer hibáznak ha egyszer hibáznak az
is már ilyen virálisan el fog terjedni
figyelj mert lehet hogy semmi sem volt
igaz amit min például ugyancsak cala
harrisnek a a beszédeint mindenféle
akcentust próbált használni amikor a
feketékhez beszélt
akkor ilyen ilyen fekete akcentust
használt amikor a latinóhoz ak latinót
és most röhögnek rajta hogy figyelj
hányfé te te ki is vagy valójában olyan
vagy mint egy kaméleon átváltozó
mindenféle színnél ami k annyira
plasztikus vagy hogy lehet hogy a
személyiségedet nem is ismerjük
egyáltalán szóval eleinte lehet hogy
kamala harrisnek a stábja azt mondta
hogy ha ha ezzel az akcentussal szólalsz
meg akkor szimpátiát válthatsz ki az
emberekből de
visszaütött én azért sokszor elmondom
neked hogy hogy olyan jó lenne hogyha
mindenki ennyire komplexen és mélyen
szeretne gondol odni és megérteni
mindent ahogy te az lenne az igazán
ideális világ én egy kicsit derülátó
vagy borulátó vagy hogy mondják ennek
vagyok ebben a
ebben a témában mert látom hogy milyen
formában lehet mozgósítani vagy
megmozdítani hatalmas nagy tömegeket de
de kíváncsi vagyok én is maradjunk
ennyibe hogy én még ehhez azért
hozzátenném ennyivel nem úzod meg szóval
még birkózzunk egy kicsit hogy hogy hogy
az egyszerű ember az aki komplex
gondolatokat nem
szokott nem szokott beszélgetni komplex
gondolatokról az ismerősi körében és ő
sem kedveli ezeket egyszerű szavakat
használó egyszerű
emberek én azt látom hogy a a
karakterérzékelésük az hogy az a másik
személy kicsoda valójában az
nagyon-nagyon pontos szokott lenni nem
tudja megmondani miért de érzi hogy
valami ott nem stimmel emléksz hogy hogy
valamikor még már lehetett vagy 20 éve
is egy ilyen rendezvényen egy ilyen jazz
koncerten segítettem valami ilyen
stábmunkába vettem részt és egy jó pár
roma család is ott volt és és részt
vettek a a tombolán és nyertek és az én
feladatom volt az hogy hogy ott a a
pólókat
kiosszam és valamilyen oknál fogva nem
jutott nekik póló vagy nem tudom olyan
homályos volt az az egész a probléma
lett belőle odament én is hogy megnézzük
hogy hogy mi a helyzet volt egy másik
stábtag aki aki ott beszélgetett velük
de láttam hogy fentről lefele beszél a a
a a romákhoz és úg én is éreztem hogy ez
valahogy nem helyes na tehát hogy hogy
valahogy úgy nem lehet tehát a ha
szavait néztük annyira nem lehetett
megmondani a testbeszéde volt szerintem
vagy a hanghordozása ami miatt egy picit
úgy fentről lefele beszélt és volt egy
ilyen nagy darab kövér bajuszos ilyen
úriember ott ilyen nagy kalappal és
egyszerű szavakkal azt mondja hogy
benned nem bízok egy az egyben megmondta
a másiknak hogy benned nem bízok é
mutatodt felém hogy benne inkább mert
azt mond a te szavaid olyanok mondta a
másiknak mint a amikor a az eső után jön
az a az a sárlés úgy folyik lefele az
árokba na olyanok a te szavaid és így
megmondta egy az egybe és és igaza volt
az az igazság hogy igaza volt tehát én
is éreztem a másik a szavait arra
használja hogy hogy elküldje őket és és
és ez a válaszom arra hogy hogy ha
valaki egy akár egy egyszerűbb valaki is
meghallja azt hogy valaki mind minden
nyájas szép szavakkal megpróbálja picit
is manipulálni a beszélgetést érezni fog
nem tudja megmondani mi történt ott
pontosan még az is lehet hogy igaza van
a másik személynek mert az igazsággal
sok minden el lehet érni de érezni fogja
hogy valami nem stimmel azért vagyok
kíváncsi nagyon hogy mi fog ezzel
történni mert mert ugye eddig a számok
nem feltétlen ezt bizonyították hogy
ha tényleg a politikát nézzük akkor vagy
vagy bármilyen nem tudom tfitekkel
kapcsolatban vagy vagy nem tudom
tudomány vagy egyébb ilyen érzékeny
témát behozva ami manapság egyre jobban
mindennél folyamatosan csak rezeg a léc
de hogy számok nem az bizonyították
eddig hogy hát most nagyon butítsuk le a
a mondatot de hogy a a j a jó
győzedelmeskedett most mondom ez ez
nagyon le van buítva mert hogy nyilván
ki lehet bontani ezt hogy mit j ent ez
hogy jó meg hogy győzdelmeskedet satöbbi
de de
láttuk láttuk sokszor olyan példát
amikor egy választásban sikerült mondjuk
a kisebbik rosszat válassza a nép de
láttuk már nagyon sokszor azt is hogy
hogy valami apró dolgon úgy elcsúszott
hogy utána nem tudtuk hogy mi van és az
nem feltétlen lett jó
emiatt van bennem nagy kíváncsiság hogy
ez át tudja-e alakítani azt az egyszerű
emberi gondolkodást ami nem egy
pejoratív értelemben mondom vagy nem
degradálni akarom egyáltalán én az
egyszerű embert mint olyan mert nem csak
egyszerűen nagyon sok ember nem akar
vagy nincs ideje vagy nem is érdekli
gondolkodni olyan komplexen mondjuk a
politikáról mint az a buborék amiben mi
mozgunk és azokhoz az emberekhez hogy mi
folyik le a végén abba a patakba mert ez
egy olyan hogy most kinyomnak egy három
órás podcastet az mondjuk egy nem tudom
én egy víztározó ühüm
aminek van egy nagy gátja és akkor
elmennek és abba a víztározóba
megfürödnek nagyon sokan de hogy az az
ember aki a küküllő végén van
ahol belefolyik egy másik folyóba hogy
hozzá miérr le abból a gátból és miérr
le hozzá hát azérr le hogy abból a nagy
víztározóból elindulnak bizonyos
gondolatok folyók kisebb videók rilsek
azt valaki megnézi a azt valahogy
értelmezi az elmondja a barátjának ott
lehet a főnöke nem tudom egy
beszélgetésen ezt továbbossza az
embereknek és az a valaki a folyó végén
vagy abba a kicsi patakba úgy megy haza
hogy hát te figyelj ide nézd meg ezt a
ezt a politikus milyen jóra való ember
közben meg lehet nem is tudott semmit
róla és a számok azt mutatják hogy ők ők
ezek az emberek akik ennyire nem
érdeklődnek ezek vannak többen és miért
mutatják ezt a számok mert a
kampányokból egyértelműen látszik hogy
ezeknek kommunikálnak te figyelj abb
gondolom hogy egyetértünk hogy a podcast
kultúra valami új valami pozitív am ez
mondom hogy nagyon kíváncsi vagyok hogy
ez mit tud rajta választani persze és
itt a most a romániai választásoknál is
nagyon érdekes hogy én amúgy követem
drágos pötrár únak a a a műsorait
pontosabban a feleségem követi jobban és
és általa én is elkezdtem figyelni de
például számomra kelemen hunor abszolút
egy pozitív tapasztalat volt és és soha
nem hallottam volna anna bircsáról
hogyha nem kell nem lett volna a része a
podcasten most már 75000en nézték meg a
kommentszekció túlnyomóan pozitív sőt
negatívat nem is olvastam görgettem egy
egy csomót egy egy egy friss szellő
gyakorlatilag a román politikába a ann
bircának a megjelenése na most ő
függetlenként indul mondhatná valaki azt
hogy zéró eséllyel de ha nem lesz zéró
az esélye szerintem a podcastnek fog
köszö köszönhetjük azt hogyha valamilyen
nagyobb eredményt el fog tudni érni hogy
hirtelen a láthatatlan részből mert ő
valójában láthatatlan lanul
tevékenykedett eddig bekerül a látható
részbe és és nagyon kíváncsi vagyok
szerintem minél láthatóbbá válik anna
annál népszerűbbé fog válni úgyhogy
kíváncsi vagyok hogy ha ide-oda elmegy a
következő pár hétben még van mennyi két
hetünk a választásokig következő két
hétben naponta két-három podcastben is
részt vesz egyszerűen hihetetlen
eredményeket fog tudni elhozni ez az én
hipotézisem azt nem hiszem őszintén hogy
meg fogja tudni nyerni a román
választásokat habár ha ha ha kéne
választani akkor én szerintem én én én
inkább rászavaznék mint mint a többire
akit eddig megláttam most ettől
függetlenül hogy hogy most
most kellemen hunor az tényleg egy
szimpatikus személy és ez a másik hogy
ami eljutott hozzám kellemen hunorról az
is ilyen szalak címek voltak nem tudtam
annyira beleásni magamat ezekbe a
dolgokba úgyhogy visszatérve magára a
podcastre számomra egy nagyon-nagyon
pozitív hozadéka volt hogy végre
megismerhettem itt a a román politikának
a a szintérén és általad is tehát
valójában azáltal hogy leültél azzal a
hogy is hívják a a é gergő gergővel
leültél ezúttal is tudok csak gratulálni
gergő
elképesztő elképesztő mélységekig tudtál
belemenni szerintem ez is csak a a
tetejét karcoltuk meg a dolgoknak nagyon
nagyon a teteje mert mert ez is volt a
cél igen jó most na azért azért kényes
tényleg ez a politika hogy mert egy
folyamatosan jutnak eszembe dolgok hogy
hogy ugye oké
valaki mondjuk egy két órás
beszélgetésben szimpatikussá válik de
mondjuk
mondjuk van egy olyan stáb mögötte most
most mondjuk hogyha így nagyon rácsapok
arra a kérdésre hogy te szabi kire
szavaznál azt mondanád rá oké jó de
mondjuk eltelik egy év és kiderül hogy
nincsen egy stáb mögötte nem ért a
gazdasághoz nem nincsen meg az a
kvalitása hogy az azokat az embereket
behozza maga mellé ami szükséges ahhoz
hogy kialakítson egy olyan csapat okat
amiben vannak egyházzal gazdasággal
kultúrával sporttal foglalkozó
szakbizottságok satöbbi satöbbi tehát
azért azért nehéz és azért komplex ez a
dolog a politikával kapcsolatban
mert mert kiderül hogy jó ember csak
csak kérdés hogy na hogy hogy fel van-e
nőve eléggé hozzá vagy tényleg megvan-e
az a hátter abszolú kérdés az hogy
hogyan döntöd el hogy valaki fel van-e
nőve úgy hogy meghallgatsz egy podcastet
és azt mondod hogy hát nem győzött még
meg tehát nagyon pozitív adja isten hogy
igaz legyen még megnézek egy podcast ott
is megjelent na hallgassuk csak meg ott
is mit mondott és és akkor elkezdesz
egyre többet hallgatni és egy idő után
azt mondod hogy te figyelj most már 10
órája
hallgatom valószínűnek tartom hogy most
már már inkább igaz amit hallok mint a
mint a amit a megérzésem mond minthogyha
egy produktum lenne legyen így hogy
tényleg meghallgatják ilyen sokan
és és amit itt még például fontos nem
hiszem a következő két hétbe fog bejönni
a podcast kultúra ide romániába hát
szerintem már amúgy be be van vagyis
hogy azért úgy látszani a a a tehát
hogyha azt mondjuk hogy román vagy azt
mondjuk hogy erdély de hogyha azt
mondjuk hogy román hogy akkor azért már
nagy nagy nagyok vannak tehát azért ott
is vannak nagy több százezres csatornák
de azt akartam kimondani h igen és ott
volt még a kulcszó hogy amiben még
érdekes játék lehet
majd hogy elmennek-e minden oldalnak a
podcastjéhez mert ugye ez is egy kicsit
olyan tudod hogy hogy akarva akaratlanul
de bizonyos ideológiák vagy bizony
függetlenek és nem
független befolyásolási tényezők mentén
kialakulnak nagy csatornák mert van aki
azt mondja hogy figyelj én ilyen nagyon
liberális vagyok én én őket szeretem
mert ők 80%-ban ezt tolják van akiről
azt gondolom hogy te ezek nagyon
függetlenek van akiről azt gondolom hogy
nekem az tetszik hogy ők ők a nem tudom
ebben a pártban csinálják ezt a
podcastet de kérdés hogy azok a
személyek elmennek-e mindenhova mert ez
lehet nagyon érdekes mert én mondjuk
liberálisként vagy nem tudom
konzervatívként kihozok belőled valamit
mert engem az érdekel de lehet hogy
mellette 30 olyan témáról nem is
beszélgettünk amiben érdekel a véleménye
és akkor hogyha elvándorol majd minden
egyes helyre akkor tud igazán komplex
lenni ez a kép abszolút és szerintem az
lesz majd a jövő hogy a politikusok nem
engedhetik meg maguknak hogy ne menjenek
el mindenhova tehát hogy hogy ha
megengedik maguknak akkor egyszerűen
ilyen összeesküvés elméletek kezdenek
gyár gyártónni miért nem ment el úgy
ahogy kamala harris miért nem ment el
joe roganhez lehetett látni egy csomó
cikk megjelent hogy biztos fél biztos h
cala harris azt mondta hogy leül joe
rogannel de 45 percet és a saját
stúdiójába tehát hogy oda elhívja és
mondta j szó se lehet róla tehát hogyha
itt ha akarsz beszélni velem akkor abba
a stúdióba beszéljünk ahol több
ezer
2223 epizódnál tart most assiszem jogan
wá és tehát látszik hogy van
mögötte jó pár ezer órányi interjú ez az
ez az aréna mindenki itt mérkőzött meg
gyere el az én stúdiómba és nem 45
percet mert 45 percet még valahogy
felkészítenek két nap alatt de
beszélgessünk három órát beszéljünk
addig ameddig a nézőknek az az érzése
oké most már ezt a hiteles oldalát
kaptuk meg ennek a kamának tudjuk meg
hogy mi ez nagyon veszélyes tehát
szerintem szörnyű lett volna tehát hogy
már csak azért megnéztem volna popkornal
a kezemben hogy hogy hogy nézzem
szenvedni kamala harris ahogy beszélt
joe rogannel
de de szerintem ez lesz a jövő tehát
hogyha most nem is ebben a választási
ciklusba de négy év múlva romániában is
szerintem az lesz hogy hogy egyre inkább
az lesz hogy lesznek majd ezek a nagyon
híres és hitelesnek tartott műsorvezetők
és akkor mint ahogy most drágos petráru
is egy egy hitelesnek tartott valaki és
akkor gyakorlatilag ha nem mész el az is
elmond valamit rólad ha elmész akkor
pedig egy csomó minden ki fog derülni
igen
egyet étek egyértelműen tehát mondom
bennem is megvan ez a kíváncsiság nagyon
kíváncsi vagyok hog hova tart de
visszaugorva az első gondolatomra én
nagyon örvendek főleg azért is örvendek
mert részesei lehetünk ennek és és
nagyon vagány dolgok
ki jöhetnek ebből az egész történetből a
következő évekbe most az hogy ki
mennyire fog a következő években vagy
kinek mennyire motivációja az hogy köz
élettel foglalkozzon majd a jövőben nem
tudom hogy te hogy látod én nekem van
egy gondolatom hogy én mit akar de de
ettől függetlenül örvendek hogy ez most
már ilyen teret hódít mert egyébként ha
azt a vonzatát is nézem hogy hogy engem
nagyon bosszant az hogy látom hogy
mondjuk a tévére milyen összegek és
milyen pénzek és milyen adók mennek- el
bizonyos tévé-knek a fenntartására még
látom hogy hogy annak a nevetségesen kis
töredékéb miket lehet létrehozni sokkal
nagyobb hozzáadott értékkel erre az
egyik legjobb példaeg szomszé
országunkban több 10000 embernek a az
adójának 1%-át ajánlották fel egy olyan
csatornának ahol ők egy évet
nagyon-nagyon kényelmesen 70 emberrel el
fognak boldogulni jó most az hogy
mennyire kényelmesen bocsánat az ilet ne
jelentsek ki de hogy azt mondták hogy ez
elegendő nekik nagyon sok mindenre de a
végén elmondta hogy a köztv ez egy nap
egy napi költségvetése és ez engem
sokkolt de többször elmondta tehát
elhiszem ne neki hogy amúg a köztvénnek
honnan van mit a köztv azt jelenti hogy
adófizetők pénzér hát az hogy most a
szomszédos országokban ez hogy működik
ezt pontosan nem tudom
de igen nyilván van egy olyan keret ahol
te azért mert szolgáltatod a híreket
vagy a nem tudom én miket ezért igen az
adónak x% helyre megy hm hát nagyon
durva na
ú tehát én ezért vagyok optimista amúgy
pont merek örvendek hogyha már azt
akarom mondani hogy hogy akarunk
spórolni és akkor ez y nagyon vagány
dolog tud lenni hogy hogy tényleg én nem
haragszom a tévé-re vagy dehogy is nem
akarom hogy tönkremenjenek a tév-k azt
viszont szeretném hogy egy kicsit
mindenki elinduljon abba az irányba ami
ami manapság kell na tehát ez ugyanolyan
mint a hirdetési felületek is ugye azért
elég elég keményen a reklámszakmába
dolgozom és
olyan próbálok úgy dolgozni a
reklámszakmába is hogy azért igyekezzek
ne termelni még több kárt amennyire az
én szintemen ez lehetséges és nagyon
bosszant az hogy olyan felületeken olyan
összegekért
hirdethetünk hogy nevetséges összegek és
sokkal több embert el lehetne érni és
valahol nem érzem ezt se korrektnek
hogy na ezt hogy hogy hogy tényleg a
kettőt párhuzamba
állítva úgy érzem mintha az egyfajta
nagy pazarlás lenne
jó egyet lapozzunk szerintem nagyon
izgalmas témákról beszélgettünk és azt
látjuk hogy az elmúlt egy év rengeteget
hozzátett rengeteg hozzánk tett épített
tanultunk
fejlődtünk hova tovább vannak-e terveid
mi mik a terveid így a ha egy év múlva
megint leülünk beszélgetni akkor akkor m
miről fogunk beszélgetni akkor
szerinted hát most terveket mondjak vagy
vagy álmokat vagy kezdjük azálmokkal
kezdjük az ál kezdjük az álmokkal hát
azért szeretném hogyha egy éven belül
most már fenntarthatóvá válna ez az
egész történet azt szeretném hogy az mit
jelentene azt jelentene hogy első és
legfontosabb hogy minden euróan hány
hány euró kéne bejöjjön magta
j hát ez van egy van egy elég nagy
kirakós ami nem tudom hogy egy éven
belül hol lesz az én vagyok kérdés az
hogy én
meg akarok-e már egy éven belül ebből
élni vagy sem szerintem nem és ezt a
kirakóst ha kiveszem akkor már kisebb
tud lenni a költség mert akkor már nem
két-három emberre kell gondolkodni hanem
egy-kettővel csak de ezt mondtad hogy
80%-ról 50%-ra csökkentené a
fényképészetet ez ez ez euróban mennyit
jelentene havonta neked hogy ezt meg hát
ezt ezt azért nem fogom tudni megmondani
most neked mert nekem ez hogy mennyire
van szükségem ez nagyon-nagyon gyorsan
és eléggé változik nekem szinte minden
évem már más abból a szempontból hogy
mire van igényem és ez általában
valamilyen téma a családunkban hordozza
tehát vannak olyan időszakaink amikor
valamire nagyon nagyon oda kell
koncentráljunk anyagilag vannak olyan
időszakaink amikor teljesen kisebb
dologgal is beérünk ez már egy ilyen
kicsit ilyen személyesebb családiasabb
dolog aminek nem tudom hogy mennyire van
értelme ebb a kontextusba
de nem nem nagyon tudom matematikába ezt
leosztani de mondjuk
mondjuk
havi havi 500 euróból már azt gondolom
hogy a csatorna nagyon-nagyon jól és
vagányul tudna
futni úgy hogy ne érezzem azt hogy
valakinek nagyon rabolom az idejét most
hogyha azt nézem hogy havi 500€ó nem
elég egy normális fizetésre ilyen
kontextusban nem elég mert mert az az
nincs egy minimál bse most meg kellett
gondolkodjak de hát egyértelműen az az
még nincs ső jövőtől közelébe se lesz am
min máb-nek mert elég nagy t meg kell
adóz ezt az 500 eurót így van így van
tehát igen mondjuk most én most a
nettóra gondoltam tehát arra amit
mondjuk ha 500€ó ami csak a csatorná ami
nem olyan elérhetetlen tehát hogyha egy
50 50 fős kemény magot sejtesz akkor
tegyük fel 10€ havonta az hát mondjuk
azért még lehet sok valakinek 10€-t
kiadni nem tűnik olyan soknak de hogyha
most csak azért hogy hogy a hogy egy
produkciót meg hallgathass lehet hogy
nem adnának ennyit igen csak annyi hogy
ez a 10 eurós dolog mellett azér még
nagyon sok mindenképp be jön tehát azér
monetizációnak ez egy nagyon kis szelete
ha engedsz teret igen ha engedsz teret
másfajta monetizálásoknak is akár
reklámoknak akár szponzorációnak akár
olyan nekem vannak olyan terveim hogy
hogy van egy ötletem 10 epizódra és
ahhoz keresek egy nagy szponzort és
akkor ez már egy ez már egy érdekes
vonal megint ami ami ami simán
hozzáárulhat ezért nehéz erről a
matekről így ilyen formában beszélni de
egy év múlva min képp azt szeretném hogy
az aki dolgozik rajta annak a munkaórája
az normálisan ki legyen fizetve ezt
azért szeretném két éves szülnapra
elérni mert azért két év alatt azt
gondolom hogy ha nem lehet elérni ezt
akkor ott valami a vezetővel van valami
baj ami én leszek
valószínű úgyhogy úgyhogy ezt mindenképp
el kellene érni ha meg a műsorokat nézem
akkor az az é nekem nagy vágyam hogy ne
csak két heti
legyen minél hamarabb szeretném azt el
érni hogy hetente legalább
egy amit nem feltétlen ilyen
terjedelemmel és ilyen hozzáadott
értékkel tudnék valószínű első körben
elérni tehát nem lennének két hetente
ennyire mély ennyire idézőjelbe vett az
én szemembe komoly műsorok de megmaradna
ez a kétheti ilyen terjedelem és hetente
be szeretnék még azért szúrni egyéb
dolgokat erre meg hatalmas a listám ühüm
igen ez
ez ilyen szempontból tényleg nagyon jó
szövetségesek tudunk lenni mert itt van
például ez az egész res kérdés az elmúlt
két hétben teljesen megváltozott a
véleményem róla tehát eddig annyira
fájdalmas és nehéz volt egy res csinálni
a hallgatók kedvéért akik akik nem
tudják hogy mi a reels ezek ilyen rövid
30 másodperctől egészen egy percesig
terjedő rövid videók amik külön egy
másik részhez mennek tehát úgy a a
facebooknak min a a youtube-nak min a
tiktoknak megvan a maga usa ez annyira
költséges és fájdalmas volt eddig vágni
legalábbis nekem hogy
hogy hogy hogy gyakorlatilag egy- kettő
tudott kimenni per epizód és most jöttem
rá valójában az elmúlt két hétben hogyan
lehet ezt gyorsan csinálni úgyhogy
minőségi legyen és
fájdalommentes valójában ezt most már te
is át tudod venni és gyakorlatilag
minden egyes dolog amit te megtanulsz az
az nekem egy segítség lehet tehát
gyakorlatilag egy év múlva az is lehet
hogy minimálisra tudjuk csökkenteni
magát azt a fájdalm részét amíg amíg
adminisztráljuk úgymond egy epizódnak az
életét és maximalizálni tudjuk a
tartalomnak a a minőségét a felkész
tehát legtöbb időt a a felkészüléssel
fogjuk tudni tölteni ez a tanulási
időnknek a jó része eddig abból állt
nekünk hogy hogy milyen fényeket
használjunk h milyen kamerát milyen
objektívet a mikrofont hogyan tudjuk
most már szerencsére sikerül
bevásároljuk azt a azt az eszköztárt ami
ami ami szükséges ahhoz hogy ezt ezt a
podcast minőségét meg tudjuk alapozni
egy év múlva én nagyon remélem hogy a az
energiádnak a 95%-a arra fog elmenni
hogy felkészülsz és magát a a forgatást
azt azt vé viszed nem tudom ez reális-e
szerinted hogy tényleg ennyire
lecsökkentsük a produkciós időt reális
tud lenni teljesen mondom abban a
pillanatban hogy hogy tényleg ha ha
valamit el tudsz juttatni egy olyan
szintre ami egyébként tudod te is a
vállalkozói
szférából érkezve hogy hogy az azért
valamit
fenntarthatóvá varázsolni és most nem
arra éírtem a fenntarthatóságot hogy
akár nem tudom magától vagy valami de
hogy ha elérrd azt a azt a nullát azt az
érzékeny nullát amikor azt tudod mondani
hogy na jó akkor ez most viszont megy
mindenki megkapja a azt az órabérjét és
ha nem is azt az órabérjét amit mondjuk
a nem tudom én milyen nagy iipari
környezetben meg tud a szakmájából kapni
de legalább azt az órabérét ami a a az
idejét valamilyen for ába honorálja az
az már tényleg egy egy nagyon kényelmes
szín tud lenni mert
onnantól leraktál egy olyan táskát amit
utána nem feltétlen kell már cipelni
legalábbis én ilyen vagyok hogy engem
nagyon bosszant hogyha ha valami valaki
nincsen tisztességesen elrendezve most
pontosan tehát hogy a a a szerintem
morálisan nem csak hogy helyes hanem
kötelező az hogy valami önfenntartó
legyen tehát hogy ha ha nem önfenntartó
tehát hogy vzteséges hosszú távon az azt
jelenti hog nem elég értékes mert
valójában az emberek a pénzükkel
szavaznak a a a ah ahol azt látják hogy
értékes valami odateszik a a a pénz
valójában az hogy a munkájuknak a
gyümölcse és valami értéket választanak
mindig mindig oda adják a pénzüket ami
számukra egy érték az ön fentartó a jó
szó nem a fenntarató igen bocsánat igen
az ön fentartó és hogy hogy hogyha ha
legyen az bármi amit csinálsz hogyha
hosszú táávon nem önfenntartó azt
jelenti nem szavazzák fel eléggé az
emberek hogy mesterségesen kell a
háttérből pampálni belé a pénzt és ez
egy nagyon jó jel szerintem a a
bizniszvilág ilyen szempontból a
realitást fenntartja hogy hogy ezt a
téves illúziót hogy valami értékesebb
mint amilyen valójában tehát tényleg ez
egy jó kis mérce hogy két év múlva
lássuk hogy mennyire fogunk tudni
haladni amúgy nekem is ez a célom hogy
most nem tudom hogy lehet nem két év
múlva de
de de lehet pont két év is tehát hogy
igazából nekem én a te válladra álltam
az az igazság hogy azáltal hogy már 10
epizódot kiment mire az az én első
epizódom elindult én egy csomó mindent
megtanultam tőled anélkül hogy konkrétan
én kellett volna kiássam úgyhogy nagyon
hálás vagyok ezért lehet hogy nekem ez a
két év le fog rövidülni majd másfél évre
vagyis le kéne rövidüljön
de hogy ugyanaz a célunk ilyen
szempontból hogy minimum a produkciós
költséget hozza ki mert ha nem akkor
akkor akkor miért ühüm igen de ez
mellett emellett hogy most csak hogy a
hogy kihozza magát önfenntartóvá
emellett tényleg az is nagyon fontos
hogy hogy
hogy azért úgy minél jobban elérjen
tényleg ez a műsor olyan szintekre vagy
olyan olyan helyekre ahol ahol ennek
lehet ennek valami foganata vagy valami
hozama mert mert ha nem megint mit érünk
vele tehát és ezért is van folyamatosan
bennem is egy ilyen kísérletező tesztelő
dolog tehát hogy már két-három olyan
dologra is rátapinthatott a kemény mag
akiket még mindig nem ismerhetek
teljesen de rá ráéreztetett olyan
dolgokra hogy hogy sokszor kísérletezünk
valamivel ami utána lehet ha nem
folytatódik vagy később fog folytatódni
de ezek kellenek ahhoz hogy hogy ezek ki
legyenek taposva úgyhogy
igen jó végezetül
egy hét múlva lesz egy podcast képzésed
és ez nem tudom mennyire lesz publikus
mennyire inkább csak egy szűk magnak
lesz viszont kicsit mesélnél erről a
képzésről mert tudom hogy ez bizonyos
szempontból ha ez a következő lehet nem
is lesz publikus ezt mindjárt elmondod
te de ezt azt látom hogy ezt annyira
értékes téma hogy érdemes kivinni a a
publikum számára is mesélj arról hogy mi
mit tervezel jövő héten és hogy hova fog
ez majd jutni és hogy hogy hogyan lehet
ehhez csatlakozni hogyha valakit érdekel
igen most kicsit össze vagyok zavarodva
a dátumokkal de valószínű ez a műsor
mikor kijön akkor már akkor már le lesz
járva ez a 19-én jön ki és hajnalban jön
ki mi pedig tehát utána fogunk beszélni
délután 4:00 órakor váó tehát akkor pont
amikor ezt az emberek itt ha valaki ha
valaki annyira gyors lesz hogy ezt az
első órákban meghallgatja akkor délután
lesz igen igen tehát hogy akkor ma lesz
a azon a napon amikor kijön ez a podcast
úgy korrekt fogalmazni aznap lesz egy
egyébként nem
nyilvános nem is képzés hanem egy ilyen
leendőbeli képzésnek a az ilyen minek
nevezik ilyen pilot vagy egy ilyen teszt
verziója
azt hogy ebből pontosan milyen képzés is
fog hosszútávon kialakulni azt igazából
az idő
fogja
visszaigazolni de első körben nekem
nagyon fontos most az hogy legyen egy
olyan dokumentumom és annak a
dokumentumnak egy olyan előadható
verziója ami tényleg ma 2024 év végén
bemutatja azt hogy mi kell egy
podcasthez kezdve a technikaitól egészen
az elmélet is síkon egészen mindenféle
címtől elkezdve satöbbi satöbbi egészen
odáig hogy ez legyártódik az is egy
hatalmas nagy fejezet és és van egy
harmadik és egy negyedik fejezet is de
ezek arról szólnak hogy mi történik egy
podcastel ha megvan az anyag mert hogy
van egy fájlunk és akkor utána még aztán
hihetetlen nagy munka jön hogy ezek ezek
milyen mi történik igazábul mi az utó
élete így neveztem
nekem ez megint egy kicsit ilyen öncélú
a van saját magamnak a legfontosabb hogy
legyen egy ilyen mert ahhoz nagyon
egyszerűen fogunk tudni nyúlni
illetve azért is mert az lenne a
médiaműhelynek is valahol hosszú támon a
célja ugye aki aki nekünk most a
legnagyobb támogatónk hogy hogy létezik
ez a stúdiónk és az ötzös udor h igen
köszönjük szépen hogy
hogy minél több embernek akit ez érdeke
át tudjuk adni úgy tudjuk ezt átadni
hogy érezzék ők is a súlyát tehát hogy
nem akarunk szerintem legalábbis én nem
akarom azt hogy most elkezdjem hirdetni
hogy ó nekem bár juthatok erre a szintre
is hogy nem tudom podcast képzők leszünk
ketten hárman akár közületek is
valakikkel vagy akár samuval is de de
első körben az a cél hogy valahol előre
segítsük ezt az édélyi podcast
kultúrát ahhoz azt gondolom hogy
kellőképp az elején vagyunk még hogy
minél hamarabb kiássuk ennek a lehető
legjobban az útját és utána segíteni
tudjunk bárkinek aki ebben érdeklődik és
akkor nézzük meg hogy hogy ezekkel miket
tudunk elérni tehát hogyha már látjuk
azt hogy van egy csakabaj van egy
navigátor van albert orsinak a a
podcastje illetve lesz a következő évben
még két-három ilyen én azt gondolom hogy
ez egy nagy siker tehát hogyha ezeket
összeadjuk és eltekintünk attól hogy
most ne nézzük azt hogy vannak olyan
csatornák akik 10000 100000 1 millió
nézővel rendelkeznek de ha erdélyben már
vannak ilyen páre ezres csatornák és
annak valahol mi is vagyunk a az alkotói
valahol ott a mélyén az nekem egy
hatalmas nagy siker lenne
ámen köszönöm szépen hogy itt voltál
levi ez egy szuper beszélgetés volt
és kíváncsian várom hogy mi fog jönni
így a a csakab baj podcastbe nagyon
kreatív ötleteid vannak rengeteget
inspirál engem is úgyhogy én csak
én csak gratulálni tudok és szurkolni
hogy akkor ássd előrre az utat továbbra
is számunkra és
igen ásd ki a az erdélyi magyar
podcastnek a a jövőjét vow van még egy
fontos dolog amit el akartam mondani én
is köszönöm szépen nektek pedig azt
üzenem hogy iratkozzatok fel a navigátor
csatornára megkérlek és írjátok le
kommentben hogyha ti egyszer podcastet
fogtok csinálni akkor azt milyen témáb
fogjátok csinálni köszönöm szépen
sziasztok kös ha tetszett ez a műsor
akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a csatornánkra
ezzel tudsz támogatni minket köszönjük a
vckker kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre